[Music]
hello everyone
can you believe we're still doing a
[ __ ] podcast every week
i can't it's it's unbearable it's almost
too much to take
um so i'm neil brennan and i
am a comedian and i'm actor
i'm not an actress a banker he's a bank
banker
i i was al capone's lawyer and i played
a capone's lawyer i played a
um i played i was at the klan rally on
chappelle show
he was looking up to been casting that i
i said let's hear for super dude when
he's fought
the milk man i believe and all that
butter boy
can't remember pretty great um
anyhow so how's your week been hon
pretty good do tell
i i don't remember actually i just hoped
you would go into your thing
i well this this was the first week i
hit i actually
felt like i hit a wall because i didn't
have
enough [ __ ] to do like
i had stand-up shows like looming all
the time
and i don't i didn't think i had one i
actually do have one this week but
i forgot what date shouted out the 17th
and i think it's uh one of those video
shows okay
um well this comes up before then yeah
so guys go
go to the non-existent website
that i for the show i don't remember i
think it's incrowd.com it's the incred
the in-crowd is the name of the thing
it's like
the the one where they have all these
monitors i haven't done a video show
so i'm a little do you think that
format's gonna stay around
no it does seem very temporary no it's
not
it's it's the it's you know if there's
nothing else you can do
if you're living in a if everyone's
breathing poison gas yeah
um the do you hear that yeah it's the
set
is it this is the mic no it's not i
think it's the set
oh okay tell you what it won't happen
again
to quote shepard smith when he said curb
job blow job
oh that was so funny what happened again
um so i hit the wall and then
so i just didn't have oh listen i might
write a book
that was the thought i had about what
just
[Music]
a bio i've done enough pretty popular
interesting [ __ ] what about but isn't
that what
thingy's gonna be about one man
not really one what about you no it is
about me but it's not it's a
it's more about a it's about an
acceptance of self that
wouldn't be uh in it would it would be
it would be like part of the narrative
of the book the narrative of the book
would be like
searching for esteem via
comedy and relationships and and
achievements
oh that's good right i like that i know
here's the problem
what i know a lot of [ __ ]
don't write and i know i mean that's the
promise i know i don't want to be a
snitch
no neil you can't and i don't want to be
a liar well also
you don't want to be boring i know
that's the thing you kind of need
i know that's what i like doing i like
reading um
[ __ ] i don't know the names on top of my
head but i like reading old the blog
no old biographies of people in the like
golden era
because when they're old they'll write
all the secrets
that's always the rubbish by the time
you're old nobody cares nobody cares and
then you could be like
they had a black son they hid in palm
springs yes
it's like yes tell me oh yeah i know all
the black sons
like i know i know all the all the
blacks all my black sons
uh but i so i it would be very difficult
to i actually had a funny idea that
i don't think would i would if i wrote
about somebody
let's say for instance dave chappelle
okay i would give him
the manuscript and let him redact it
the whole thing comes i know that would
be funny like just whole lines of like
no no redacted redact um
but yeah that's i also don't want to
write a tell
i don't know it's in i know objectively
that it's interesting
but at the same time i don't want to
write all the press would just be like
you said dave hit you or what you know
what i mean he didn't he never hit me
i was like um uh but or whatever just
like
all that dumb conflict [ __ ] so i'm in a
tough spot
and i also may write a pilot because
schultz reminded me of something andrew
schultz what
he just reminded me of like just gonna
be the word is it gonna be the bird the
bird mauling
no uh that's only hallmark
um lifetime maybe schultz it just
reminded me of like a thing i did
he's like that's good and i'm like i
know but he just like
reinvigorated you guys had the come up
of the of the
of the uh of the pandemic you think he's
been doing better he's pretty popular
before
he's he's doing a netflix hour oh
about the year oh yeah did not know that
yeah
that like is gonna start airing december
17th that
is based on his instagram videos that's
amazing yeah it's [ __ ] awesome
it's also great because you
can't argue with it you can't say
[ __ ] if you're in comedy you can be like
[ __ ] look at the system
yeah if you make a video on your own if
you make a bunch of videos on your own
that are popular
you'll get called up to the majors
what's what
how could you possibly not like that
speaking of which
if you're looking for uh another
sort of hard ass uh seinfeld was on
tim ferriss's podcast and he did like an
hour and 45 but
he it's basically just like yeah if you
work hard
you will succeed he wrote he used to
write three days a week
mitzi shat on him and he started writing
seven days a week
yeah when he went he came to the store
after i think the last time he was there
was in the late 70s or early 80s and he
said
he said that she shattered him and he
was like i'm never coming back
he made her like a totem right i'm like
i'll show you guys
i will show you and he said something
that i'd never i don't know if he said
before but
tim ferriss said like have you did you
ever get to speak to her and he goes
he goes no but when i was doing um the
sitcom
uh when i would drive i had a beautiful
house at the top of the
hill in hollywood and when i would drive
to the studio
i would always see mitzi walking her
dogs
and he goes i never waved or smiled but
i always made eye contact oh my god i
love it
but it was a lot of [ __ ] like that where
it's like oh yeah this guy's a
maniac but in the best possible what
um do you remember what you did this
week yet
i just watched [ __ ] documentary i
watched so many documentaries this week
i just had nothing
i know sometimes like i saw your list
like jesus christ
watching documentaries morning noon and
night
i kind of did i emotionally was a little
depressed too but i'm
moving on it was a little bump just
because i didn't
have the
i also realized the upside and down side
of the vaccine is
uh bill's policy it's great now
[ __ ] you um is uh
who doesn't you can't overcome bell's
palsy you [ __ ] come on
hard ass you're [ __ ] [ __ ] these
are so cool
um no it's just knowing like oh i'm not
having a normal
anything for six months yeah i
like i'm knowing that yeah it's just
it's a little
you got to trick yourself into thinking
vaccines coming in three weeks it'll be
normal and then
you you read two articles and you're
like [ __ ]
i feel like we're the most prepared for
uh six more weeks of winter you know
there's like bad news like no still not
letting up like i feel just numb to it
i'm like yeah sure of course
yes maybe next year yeah
i was supposed to start a show in march
oh
new york this past march and then i was
like well maybe yeah
and then i'm like july keep just d just
tell yourself
two years
i won't be happy with two years no and
then you'll be happy but
i'm talking about now i'm not don't want
to be miserable now so that i'm
surprised hey self surprise
like i need something to look forward to
not not the worst
think of the worst possible outcome what
have you been looking forward to
[ __ ] um uh open air [ __ ]
or no and actually closed air open air
don't even like the outside like a pod
like a japanese pod [ __ ]
um i'm just saying aren't you haven't
haven't you hasn't this feeling like
aren't you used to it yes but i just
want it to be over
it's because you got to do a little uh
stand up
you got to taste it yeah i can still do
that show
i just i for some reason it felt like
i'm just kind of
not repeating myself yeah it's just like
you know the hour works like i know
it's i need place where i can do new
jokes so um
i'm looking forward to not having to
worry about it
i just want to not worry about it i know
and and
like the i did have the pressure of
having a show coming up and like
prepping for it
and i was i just had this the first week
i wasn't really prepping for anything
um so it was just kind of but then i
today i was like ah hey not so bad
okay yeah so moving on
now in the in terms of the country uh
that the deaths are it's the
deadliest week in american history yeah
did you see that
meme going around that says the
the most deadly days for americans oh
yeah like
9 11 last thursday last friday but by
the way 9 11 is not even number one
no no no no no yeah yes it is like
pearl harbor and you see the pearl
harbor numbers you're like why do we
even know about that
well yeah now i don't know if we're numb
to it we're like that wasn't that many
or if it's so many and we're just the
thing about pearl harbor 9 11
spectacular
their respect they were especially they
were spectacular
they were a movie this is not a movie
this is a traffic jam
of people you don't know and kind of the
the least valued people in the society
old infirmed and uh
latino black native american it's like
okay well that's not gonna be it's not
gonna feel like much to
mainstream society and it's you see
other people trying to go like my
someone died and it's always a little
like i my so and so such and such died
and you're like that's a little indirect
none of it
is some of it's like my dad died right
there's a few people my dad died or my
mom died
um but and speaking of my mom dying my
mom
emailed me and said she had to make a
reservation to go to church on christmas
at which point i don't know if i went
all caps but i was like don't go to
church
you can't get like no no
i didn't know like you cannot cross the
street she like
bites she didn't respond and then i
texted my sister like she can't go to
church she's like
we told her we're not going and i was
like she does she may not know that
she's still packed she's still got her
outfit lately
it's like two weeks in advance yeah like
[ __ ] looking at it
no my grandma is like i go to church
i'm like okay i like do you need and her
her response is i mean i'm gonna die at
some point
i'm like okay i mean okay cool
okay i'm gonna come and punch in the
face we'll take we'll take we'll take
your chances right
we'll just see what happens it's just so
annoying on the freeway
what do you run on the freeway what are
you doing you're gonna die sometime
it's this thing of like god is cool it's
it's this dumb calculation
of there is a god and
it's cool with it needs me to go to
church it's the sacrifice thing i know
this is i'm showing my devotion and it's
like
i also think it's some true g [ __ ] like
i'm a rider
no dude just [ __ ] stay home give it a
second just go to church twice in june
uh yeah but i also think it's a form of
like that's your stand up for old ladies
uh in terms of uh structure yeah you
could you could have just
i mean you gathered people did you did
you not it was outside
but i'm just saying like we no yeah i'm
with you uh
they cut off outdoor seating for a
reason even though it's outside like
there is
a level of selfishness we've all been uh
like guilty of so i think with old
ladies this is like all they got
yeah i just wouldn't do anything inside
without a mask
without double masks fantastic we're a
hazmat suit like stop
it's they don't get tested also people
who are old people are at risk they
don't get tested that much because
they're not really going that many
places
but i don't know do you think teresa is
going to go
with everyone was like no one's going
mom
i guess she wouldn't go she'd basically
watch it on tv
what do you think make everyone frozen
sandwiches what do you think is gonna
happen
i just don't understand that god's gonna
be like so what happened christmas 2020.
talk to me what no no have a seat please
chris god comes out like chris hanson
teresa lemonade kitchen god from the
bible
uh to have you talked to her like
candidly about
coronavirus i don't know how to how do
you define candid like meaning
hey do you like this is real are you
okay uh yeah early on i felt like i was
talking about
i i felt like the parent it was like the
full circle moment
of being like no you cannot
go mine you cannot go my mom was like
just come up
we don't mind and i was like that's
actually not how the
virus works yeah
uh so they think if
you're they think that the virus cares
about intention
no it's not a person 2020 is not a
person
providers not a person doesn't not
anthropomorphizing it's not it's not the
pixar movie
uh no i do find that some people are
very
very vocal about the trump
administration and anti-massacres and
just like can you believe it
but or equally as careless yeah it's
like people who are for the environment
have kids
wow what a jump can't do both what a
jump
can't do both you're a climate change
denier you heard it here
now speaking of the trump administration
a lot of people are saying
um so he did the
what they think is that what we thought
was the final
motion at the supreme court and they got
booted right
that was so funny that was like that
yeah it wasn't
but the alito and justice thomas
they basically i know but it's confused
it's just it
would have been funnier if it was like
no right
but once you're in like we don't like it
but we don't we should have standing all
that [ __ ] it is interesting that
all of his that's but that's also weird
that they thought
well we got our judges in there it's
like that's the joke i did on on uh
he thinks that the the the attorney
general
is generally his attorney yeah and he
thinks that the supreme court are
my judges they're my they're literally
my judge they do things that
that i like because i hired them i hop
this is a thing i own
and i hired them to come and judge for
me
like you're [ __ ] a [ __ ] um but uh
he now i said today on twitter that he
is now
he is the he's the vegetative pres he's
terry schivo
he's oh you gotta bring her into it why
not
what happened to her again what'd she
get like that she got
she she went to church no wow oh she
goes she's something taken out
no i don't she was a vegetable yeah she
but she got me
coma she yeah coma but more specifically
uh it was that she should have been
um she was in a persistent vegetative
state
and it was that then everybody she went
into cardiac arrest
and then okay she was had a massive
brain damage due to lack of oxygen
to her brain um so they had her on
computers and synthesizers for
they had her on [ __ ] for years and
that's what trump is basically like
he's on a ventilator even though he's
not on eventually schumacher his
yeah his his his
presidency is in a vegetative state
it's technically it's worse than a lame
duck it's a lame duck on life support
it's no he's not doing [ __ ] no it's like
the in terms of pursuing maybe he'll be
another four years like no no this yeah
you've got people pretending in the
[ __ ]
it's weakened at first yeah it's weekend
at bernie's
weekend it's such a [ __ ] it's sleepy
yes and then people the other thought i
had was people saying
that this will be a stain on the
republican parts
what the [ __ ] are you talking about no
one remembers [ __ ]
no one remembers anything no one
remembers
that he got um impeached and none of
them use this will be a permanent thing
it's all a permanent stain they have
they have stain guard
they have that thing where you pour
water all over yourself and it just runs
down yeah the rain-x
yeah they have rain-x they're covered in
rain-x
um they're they're right
rain ex republicans uh
their their elephant is covered in rain
x they
they're not no one remembers [ __ ]
yeah no people don't people don't take
into consideration what politicians do
and
add them in real time all it's just
there's too much [ __ ] no one
there's too much [ __ ] and also our
metabolism
is too fast that you don't even remember
the impeachment
for sure that's what i mean covid and
trump
and and also the internet there's no
[ __ ] history what do you
i don't even know what they're talking
about like permanent stain
it didn't even go into the fat it's
reynax is that what it's called but
it's called vaynex but the thing is when
i think about
what when republicans made us think
about obama i think of
mustard benghazi but
that is great but they look like morocco
no but it's just like
because they try to make a big deal
about nothing and by the way it kind of
helps them
in a weird way because it makes people
becomes a boy who cried wolf thing where
you just go what are they saying now
they're saying the other side a lot it
just becomes all of them are the same
when
there's republicans are in my opinion
orders of magnitude worse when it comes
to dumb [ __ ] and
and travel gates and [ __ ] things
when somebody i mean they're going to do
it to to biden poor beau
now poor beau died the hunter
hunter poor hunter it's going to be
hunter all
day long yeah fine i i just don't care i
don't
that's fine it also hunter
had yeah what hunter what about hunting
let me this is my dot this is my my my
blank on hunter
okay egomaniac narcissist
a drug addict and all of his
contrition is performative
that's what i think i don't know i also
i don't think he's a bad guy
but i'm just saying when i look i just
like oh i know this kind of guy
you know this guy yeah i mean when he
got together with the dead brother's
wife he did some weird [ __ ] there's a he
has a kid with a strip
he just has like the hunter's basically
a rapper
all you need to know from hunter is that
that that uh laptop
shot you know that they took from his
that they saw
well i never even saw the picture well
hunter biden uh
hacked laptop yeah
oh i don't know i don't know about the
picture yeah that one right there with
this
it's like ah yeah what's he doing he's
smoking
every [ __ ] everybody in the world has
that picture uh no he looks rough
he's he's a cool drunk yeah he looks
cool but he definitely looks like he
he he's down with
all sorts of whatever whatever you need
whatever's happening this guy
he's getting you whatever you need yeah
yeah he knows a guy
yeah look it's i'm gonna have to skim
i'm gonna take a little off the top
um yeah i don't so whatever so
um so yeah i don't i
just the the permit it's like shut up
about the permanent state and i got
people got mad at me on on twitter when
the impeachment happened
when they were like history will
remember mitt romney
and i was like history he's not right i
remember sheamus the dog
on his [ __ ] people's no it's like
you'll go oh by the way he
voted for impeachment in a vote that
didn't make a difference because he knew
he wasn't gonna pass
like who gives a [ __ ] you know what
they're talking about though they're
talking about
the kind of score keeping or um
check and balance that the 24-hour news
cycles do because they'll pull some
they will pull they will pull a clip
from years ago
to you know it's like they're all so in
that world right
it's like this will be the same thing
that you someone
but it's not rel it's not important in
any way
it's not important like and they tried
and
it's you did this what about bush vegar
just like i don't know what about okay i
have a question do you think
how fatigued we are on [ __ ] politics
at this point um throughout the last
four years
do you think that's gonna carry over to
biden or do you think we're gonna start
caring
all of a sudden he's not because he's
not a star so you think we're gonna
no i mean do you think we're gonna if
something happens do you think we're
gonna care
i feel like our caro meter is broken
it's like just [ __ ]
get us back to work uh
i still think people care i think
they're exhausted
but i think they care i think people pay
attention even though they don't want to
i i if it's if i don't if i'm not online
it's because i'm
i had an ayahuasca revelation but you're
different
like for example i didn't know all of
the
like i don't rem always remember obama's
a.g
i don't remember maybe you do you know
i'm sure you do right
there we go like when you say it i'm
like oh yeah but with trump he was
so such a star he had such star power
that we
everybody participated a lot more than
general do you think we're gonna go back
to like
not really caring because obama was a
star too and it was black so it was like
get black ag and yeah
yeah um i don't i just think it's like
you need a star you need
someone you need a charismatic person
and an ongoing narrative and i don't
think
biden has it no it's just not
he's not fun to watch i'm happy he's
president
but it's not fun to why he's not smooth
and he's guessed like he's
like but he's stammering every speech he
bombs it's not even like the stammer
he [ __ ] words up yeah
it's kyle uh done against impression i'm
so goddamn fine
it's so good so
the the i just don't buy that there's
gonna be a permanent stain
and and like barr got fired today
did he get fired well yeah like i mean i
just had a nice talk and he's going to
leave
a week away in a week um is there
anything for bart
he resigns whatever no that's a there's
it's like it's over it's okay
so he's not gonna be able to like clean
his desk out and like play
solitaire for the last three weeks but
even this didn't like
it just happened when we were settled
[Music]
but
the these guys are heroes sorry which
guys when people are like
he'll live in in uh infamy no we just
gonna live in [ __ ] wealth by working
for
white shoe republican law firms these
guys are heroes for the rest of their
lives
if he goes to the
8 30 club in dc he's going to get booed
yeah but he ain't going he's just going
to go they know where they're wanted
they're just going to
stay in the bubble stay where they want
to that's correct and also it's like
florida mar-a-lago so it's like you'll
be fine
he'll be it's again he can't really go
back to new york yeah you go to
you go to you become like i'm big and
i'm big in
uh indonesia you just [ __ ] hang out
in indonesia my friend
i don't know if i told you this my
friend she's french
and she uh has like her uncle owns a
store of
a chain of grocery stores on a small
island off the coast of france or some
french-owned
island and she did a commercial for him
and one time she when she went back and
visited probably 10 years later
everyone's like
you're the girl from the commercial and
she's liter she's one of the most famous
people
in this little tiny island that like no
one's ever heard about
yeah and i'm like that's basically that
but for half for
half the country 70 million people 70
million people she's
he's the [ __ ] yeah he's he's in that
commercial
he's the guy from the grocery store yeah
basically that's what he
really basically is that's um there was
moving on the there was a mag of march
on saturday was it where it was like
dc in dc yeah yeah a lot of uh what
happened
a lot of gl a lot of guys and gloves i'm
sorry oakland are we
still what are we protesting they don't
nothing they just want to get they just
want to be
like wow it's like you know when guys
a bunch of guys need to do a chore and
it becomes like a thing like yeah i got
my
we're going to move the thing they make
it what's happening they make it
or they make it like the oh i brought my
the winch
or whatever the [ __ ] you i don't i like
we got to get something out of the river
and then it becomes like a whole thing
of like
masculine like you gotta lift up
everybody explaining things
you're gonna um that's what this
is writ large now the problem is
people that should know better counter
protesters
show up and then one got shot few got
stabbed
oh yeah yeah i saw that gang now i got
gang four stabbed
just let them let them they without
tension without resistance it's a it's
it's a fire that puts itself out yeah
exactly
they're not gonna be able to do anything
um they vandalized some black churches
pretty cool wow really yeah pretty cool
there you go there's the boy they've got
my gloves
all i'm wearing them cool gloves
and you're all fat all of you are fat
uh to a person and the only people that
are in shape have cameras so they're
photographers
you hit fat fat old uh disgusting
unfuckable white taliban is what they
are
they're white helmets same as those same
aesthetics different trucks
uh yellow goofy [ __ ]
kilts it's so funny how uk and like
commonwealth culture has
um morphed into this in this country
like uh a lot of my
jews will replace you oh my god
china oh this is the uh is fun the
police
this is the side this is the counter
protesters but why are they against jews
because they the maggot guy said jews
will not replace us
oh okay so it's like both slogans bad
jews will repression no they
both slogans not good as what
pharmacist what are you talking about oh
my god
no that sign your nose and throat
doctors jews will replace you
uh no that sign's not good yeah china
big
these sound races too chingamigra
ochinga thank you
i don't know what that means either
they're bad again this is
losers this is the lefty losers and
they're also
like i mean i agree with more of the
what they have to say
but i don't think we should defund the
police uh
jews aren't replacing anybody and i
don't know what [ __ ] maze
i don't know what that means and i don't
even want to look at it um
so what i would say to uh people that
are more sympathetic to
our point of view just don't go it's
there it's like arguing on twitter
it's just so [ __ ] waste of time just
well
mute it are you telling people not to
know arguments but then i'll mute it
wow i don't think but i don't i won't
like talking [ __ ] and vlogging so much
no it's great because everybody thinks a
thing's happening i don't even know
about it
okay but i don't i only i don't like
intentionally write something and go
like we'll see
i'll write something that i mean people
will go
you're gonna get in trouble and then i
just mute it so nothing
happens and then they try to bring it up
in my permanent record like
that's why kelly clarkson's daughter
should have a just for fans joke that
you made
two months ago that i'm trying to that i
can't even remember
kellyanne contract yeah kellyanne kalian
clark
kelly and clarkson killian um
so uh
so just don't go to these protests and
let them they
they thrive on resistance that like
these
these protesters need a thing like what
[ __ ] you
and then be just don't go at the
at charlottesville
don't that one was different yeah
because this is a trump rally you know
what you're getting this they were
protesting
an actual thing and then there were
counter protests the actual thing
yeah that one i understand a lot more
but this is just like
they lost yeah they lost and they're
trying to like they're like
lookie here they're lucky hearing right
basically
they're just looking here i'm like look
here well well well
all throughout dc like well well well it
isn't the supreme court they're trying
to intimidate a building
um uh so just
uh don't pay attention um we kind of
covered covid
yeah um a basketball player
is in a coma right now of florida a kid
who plays for florida
um he went up for
a dunk in the middle of the game and
there was time out and he came out of
the car
out of the out of the timeout and just
collapsed is this
nba no florida the state uh
or something florida university of
florida um
so he now is in a coma
or he's maybe he's out of it he's in
critical with stable condition
here's the here's the here's the thing
that's not in the first
he had covered like three months ago so
it's that long covered thing where it's
like yeah maybe you [ __ ]
pass out in the middle basketball games
if you there there's a
there's a a this hank gathers died like
30 years ago he's a basketball player
20 years 30 years ago uh basketball
player
and a college player and he had a heart
disease that he didn't really know about
and this could be long coveted
that's where where when i think about
going on vacation i'm like [ __ ]
i know i mean i still have very weird
stomach issues
you know interesting do i want to hear
about them
oh yeah no it's not gross um i don't
get hungry until remember i was
like not eating until seven eight
o'clock yeah but no hunger pains
and i could go i could probably go two
days without feeling hunger pain
and it was so heavily in my stomach it
was just this
oh it was awful feeling my stomach i
just think it's permanently
weird it's nice i guess some people
would argue you know it's not the
opposite i'm not constantly having
hunger but it's real there's times where
i like
i need to eat yeah i am not eating i'm
eating i probably
once a day grits and eggs
what is that grits and eggs grits and
eggs okay
yes thank you thank you white guy
collard greens collard greens
collard greens uh it's weird yeah i mean
i said what only it's the only
the only difference is the covet yeah i
said last week somebody i know
we know three and a half months couldn't
taste or smell
healthy young black guy you know what's
funny too
is that i know someone that
have that had the antibodies eventually
but in
february so we don't know when he got it
but he had
a heart attack and they had no idea he's
like 32
33 had a heart attack had two heart
attacks they had no idea
why and then a short time later he
tested positive for the antibodies and
it was it was weird like no
no no um did not fit one statistic to
have a
any cardiac issues and then he tested
positive for
igg and so it's like he everybody thinks
yeah i don't i don't want that okay did
i just scare you
no i don't i'm aware of all that stuff i
mean i talk
people have a long people i know
these thirty people [ __ ]
[Music]
have this have long symptoms and or long
after effects and it's like i have zero
interest in that
yeah i'm i i'm stir crazy
but it's a bit like being in a bunker in
in
in war where you're just like just just
stay in a bunker just go somewhere
close yeah
i i'm with you listen i know plenty of
places
i'm with you but i want warmth okay
that's where you get into like you know
80.
i want 80. give me 80.
give me 80. padre was 80.
um yeah well 80 is tough right now oh
honey 80's tough buddy i know i that's
the problem buddy hey buddy
yeah buddy right here that's the that's
the that's the issue
um okay so i but i also don't want to
have a heart attack
or not be able to taste you guys know
that tasting is one of my favorite
things
i love sniffing ellen sick
sick production ellen at home
you want to know how sick she is didn't
text me back
wow that's how sexual first time i think
it is the first time
the first time she's ever not yes she's
very punctual with text
oh yeah i thought you text her once and
you didn't she didn't respond
no she did and no she's always she's
always responding that's a that's a good
uh
that's a good skill i mean she's got a
high batting average yeah
um uh
but yeah that's how in fact worse than
not texting went to green
so i don't know what's happening wait
wait a minute you texted her and
the thing turned green maybe she was
wisened up and got a
galaxy no nobody's had she doesn't need
money that badly
um i don't know guys we're in
real trouble
i can't live with it i'm gonna call the
local hospitals
and then have the cops do uh breakouts
oh well um yeah wellness check thank you
um are you worried
about her no she'll be fine she like
posts the picture which is fine
um the she'll get whatever she needs to
get i'm sure too
are you gonna get it well all right so
moving on
i you can't i talk to somebody
we talked to somebody i know knows a
billionaire
the billionaire said i'm just deciding
which brand to take and then i talked to
another billionaire
and he's like i'm not going to jump the
line which i don't know if he got
offered it
uh that sounds like i'm not gonna he'll
uh no but it's he's like i'm gonna wait
my turn he's gonna i'm gonna
offered it no um but jump in the line
like that's he's not gonna jump the line
he's not gonna double the line
if he's not gonna go before a nurse
right you want to jump the line that's
the weird thing
i want the [ __ ] vaccine right now you
would take it
what am i waiting for i just want oh
wait hold on guys this is where we
realized that
that bianca is a anti-vaccine no i'm not
hold on guys
um heavy metals mercury uh
no i'm just be nice if a whole round of
people got it before me
why because you don't trust it no just
everything i've researched about
vaccines and how long they generally
take to find out all the
side effects and stuff it would just be
nice to not be first string
i'm i will have it it's not wild but i
don't think it's wild i think it's
flirting with antibacterial no
what the [ __ ] it's not at all
anti-vaccine means i think you're
flirting pretty heavily i think you
have your your cleavage no i'm going to
church
on christmas okay uh no i don't no i'm
just
i want to see all the side effects i
don't think they don't work
or they cause what do you think they'll
do when they have side effects what do
you mean
they will do what do you think
whatever the companies will do
astrazeneca and all that if there's a
lot of side effects from
a vaccine they like they halt the
vaccine they try to figure out what's
going on they'd retest and stuff
okay i mean they tested it the numbers
of people they tested on i feel like
they would have gotten
they had a lot of [ __ ] people yeah
you know i know i look like
i saw a hundred was a hundred thousand
uh i think
in how many countries i think it was
it was uk do you know the number
of the number no no because i thought
there was i don't know how many total
they did it because they did in a few
countries
can you do how many people um
i don't know how many people thousands
tens of thousands ten
yes i read one today that's at least uh
oh
yeah that's a really good amount of
people no no for sure
so i'm just i don't i would rather i
i get that there's some risk i happen to
just kind of inherently trust
institutions because i because i'm white
because you're right
and you can say it uh i'm white and
because i think we need institutions to
have a society that runs well we need
the new york times we need the
washington post we need
legacy media and drug companies
right um it's not worth
putting out a it's not worth putting out
something that's going to
kill people oh no yeah no i'm not saying
i believe in vaccines
okay you're telling me as if i don't
believe them well no i don't even
because someone who doesn't believe in
vaccines and that they actually are like
no they're trying to like well that's
what i'm saying
so 50 of people that they pulled so far
said they'll take it no questions asked
26 26
don't know if they're going to take it
or not and 23
um are 20 whatever 24 are
they're not taking it and it's like okay
you're just these are not the people
that don't
they don't know anything about science
they never have they know about like
they never have they've never known
about science ever in their entire life
all of them have their immunizations
right yes that's a whole lot of the
funniest thing they all have no measles
no
you've never gotten polio yeah no polio
all of it they have mo let's say all of
them have it and
suddenly they got advanced degrees in in
immunology and they just want to be it's
a
it's the the question on the on the
study minus would be like hey are you
are you a sucker
people go nah yeah that's it just like
no i ain't
i just want the record to show i ain't
no [ __ ]
like okay i'm a [ __ ]
okay i'm a i neal i'm just trying to
keep it real yeah
yeah like i'm trying i don't [ __ ] with
that yeah you [ __ ] with every you [ __ ]
with
aspirin you [ __ ] with it if you're like
the hardcores jamaican who doesn't do
anything like that
fine but just like a guy who like
who there's this group of people who who
who every conspiracy is believable
no questions asked no questions asked no
it's like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
don't
so you what you think we need to ask
questions of everybody except the
conspiracy theorist
like no him i don't him i would never
stoop
to ask the simplest follow-up i would
never insult him like that
but a company that's been around for 150
years
i got a few questions yes um everybody
that i know that's anti-vaccine i don't
know that many but you know on facebook
old high school people they've all done
cocaine
of course they have like i've seen you
do cocaine not
i haven't necessarily seen all of them
but i know everyone is partied
i'm like how into heavy metals were you
when you were yeah they weren't yet
somehow it's just selective it's like
ecstasy we had no idea cocaine hunter
biden
were partying with hunter um they went
uh hunting stupid um
yeah so go [ __ ] yourself it's the
did you watch the bt documentary which
we'll get to no i watched i was
finishing
i'm finishing the [ __ ] room the
accusation okay
uh bg's documentary there's a point
in in it's great it's great because they
have stories of how
how they wrote songs cool and i love the
beauty how they developed
the sound the multiple
basically an accident they were just
like
go in and do ad-libs on
jive talking i think it was java one of
their one of their like
pre-hits first of all they wrote
how do you mend a broken heart 10 years
before
sunday favor so they were like they were
a well-known band
um i won't get into it but there's a
point where
do you remember the disco sucks movement
i
wasn't around for it but i remember so
there was a dj in chicago named steve
dahl
and they had a disco sucks rally
in the middle of a white sox game
in 1979. in a doubleheader they had a
rally
on the field 1979.
my brother was an usher no and got
punched in the face
and i remember the next morning i was
five
and i remember thinking then why would
you be against disco
i just was like that's so like
it was a [ __ ] right but i remember
just thinking like this is
like what a dumb thing do you how was it
i know you're only five but what was the
feeling like where did that come from
well did you just go just take it it's
the same
chris martin from coldplay had a good uh
object he's in the documentary and he
goes
at a certain point it's there are no
more interesting opinions about the bg's
other than like no i don't like them
no [ __ ] that it's like where people get
like [ __ ] the macarena and you're like
all right is that actually
you know what i mean like like that
simple like low-hanging fruit
shitty dumb person premise was disco
just
everywhere i don't get i feel like it
probably took over a little bit
yeah it was um
[Music]
ed well now culture's so splintered that
something can be really popular and you
can
completely avoid it whereas then it like
it got it infiltrated right it
infiltrated radio
clubs like they would open nightclubs
to have disco to have a disco it was
just
disco clubs which is what siren favors
about
sound favors basically a
sports movie but dancing that's funny
that's what i mean it's like we gotta
enter the contest
i gotta do the contest like that's the
that's the premise
and they all had contests like that was
real no but it's good it's a good frame
for
a movie what i'm saying so i mean every
language
i in most european languages the word in
most languages the word for
nightclub is discontent i know disco
tech still the best
i still love saying that like you want
to go to a disco
that's [ __ ] funny i'm old yeah i'm
old i tell you
uh so that's what anti-vaxxers are like
nah
i don't [ __ ] with disco the macarena
[ __ ] skinny jeans i ain't no bitching
no skinny jeans
i don't okay cool man all of a sudden
and i'm against that it's like
so you're dumb are you a dumb person nah
i'm the smartest [ __ ] you ever
met you know no you're not
the problem is that when you tell
someone that they're actually
not someone that thinks they are so good
at critical thinking
that they are not doing like an ounce of
critical things they're just taking
misinformation
and like regurgitating it i mean how do
you tell someone like
dude there's a you don't get it there's
a thing called the dunning-kruger effect
which is yeah
the people that are the least competent
people
think they're the most confident
uh yeah the uh they they just believe
like it's it's done in career like for a
long time it was like a thing that women
were saying about men in comedy and it's
kind of like you men are pretty good at
comedy though
um but like they think it's chelsea uh
pretty you see that joke about every guy
thinking they killed
when they get off which is a [ __ ]
great joke it's really funny i happen to
not
live in that world but um
but yeah it's just that
it's that it's the i'll talk about it
more because someone wrote
there were a bunch of letters about
people
the guy who thinks he can do stand up
and like somebody
some some guy makes a bets bet wants to
make a bet in a letter
that is so dumb okay i'm excited it's so
dumb that i want to talk more about it
you know what it's like one remember
when it was like
laurel yanny that [ __ ] yeah
i heard the one most people weren't
hearing yanny
and you're like it's saying laurel i'm
like no it's not
it's saying well that is a genuine
perception issue
no i understand that oh no it's like
actual frequency but when someone was
trying to tell me
no dude it's laurel like you can't tell
me it's
it's not saying well yeah then another
thing kicks in but what that's
it's really hard to tell people that
what they truly [ __ ] believe is
nonsense well that's
why that's the problem with fox news and
and and uh whatever the [ __ ] another
one's called own america's talk
own uh news oh yeah newsmax
yeah like you can't explain to them like
your production value on those
solo it's uh public access um
with slightly better looking people yes
uh you can't
explain to a ignorant person that
they're ignorant because then you're
like
you think you're better than me no i
just happen to know the fact
what even is a fact i need to see how
they did it
okay man on everything let me guess but
not
food and cocaine you're fine you assume
red bull is red bull
and you assume math is meth and you
assume all the other [ __ ] that you just
inherently trust you [ __ ]
i don't even know what to call them
because i i pity these people
um cleveland indians
no really say goodbye what are they
changing
uh the
best options hit that hit that here's
some of the best
including the spiders and the rockers
spiders
they're gonna go with rockers because
they're still trying to rock the the
hall of fame thing
spiders naps i don't get that cleveland
naps
[Music]
maybe they're saying i don't [ __ ]
know yeah maybe oh they were called the
now cleveland fellers i thought it was
fields
bob feller an author of legendary oh
he's the author of a legendary fastball
the greatest patron
he's the author of a fastball he wrote
he would write he would write letters
and then hand them to the pitchers and
they would say fastball
and then the umpire would hand them a
note that said strike
it was a weird way but it works
uh cleveland cuyahoga's they're gonna go
with rockers
blue socks why not uh because of red
socks and white socks
hazards that guys burning river is kind
of funny burning riverside
and it still sounds native okay how
about the cleveland nowheres
um how about the cleveland lebrons steve
huh uh are we talking
i you know again should have these are
these are not bad
um they're not
uh yeah then people no they
native americans don't even mind it it's
like first of all why'd you say native
american
huh because you know not to say indian
right
but uh and also it's one one study from
a long time ago
they don't care it's like no there's
other studies where they say they really
care
yeah they can't but there's one
um the the global warming's the host
um oh this is interesting and a side
note
um biden
by nano oh we should have talked about
two weeks ago when obama
said that when you get into a slogan
like defund the police
you're dead to rights because you're too
easy to paint as
socialist radical yeah and all that [ __ ]
and then biden basically said the same
thing on a
recorded phone call he did i will say
that was about the phone call
he sounded competent and angry which i
liked
he he just sounded like hey man he was
doing the hey man yeah
hey
um so
i don't i mean i think we are both
pretty
realistic about defund the police as
being just a dumb
no what was the better one reef on the
police it's refund refund
that's what they just need to move money
around yeah or
they don't refund they just need to
refund the police
on the bus and then the police are like
we're getting uh we're getting we're
going to run back back
uh um uh
it should be refund the police and yeah
cause then it feels like
yeah we're not getting rid of police
hello we're gonna send a bunch of
therapists
yeah but this is a problem with slogans
it's that
either so here's the problem they're
great and people love them
here's a problem with jingles um no the
problem is like uh
white privilege black lives matter
defund the police
it feels like you've gotten i feel like
the people who make them okay so if you
want i think we talked about it
it's the person it's like do you want uh
do you want a good
a good uh attention grabber okay but
then
you're gonna have to sacrifice really
communicating effectively to the target
demographic so if you're saying white
privilege okay
that's look i'm listening what excuse me
that brown woman's listening no no
everyone is like
gonna react to white privilege white
people
when they hear white privilege they go
this doesn't sound good for me
no that's what i'm saying so at this
point i don't i don't know even know
what this
is and i don't like it i don't know if i
would hey get away from my wallet
so white privilege for example that's
when i get my gun like the guy
yeah and st louis well i got my that's
bug assault
uh no my gun like the couple bonnie
yeah yeah um so when let's just take
white privilege
at that point you don't
care if whites understand
you know because either you're taking
whites out of the equation
you're like [ __ ] you i don't care if you
like the slogan
and at that point i think you get these
slogans when people do get pushed i
don't think there's
a beginning of an issue and then you
know
jim clyburn said um james i call him jim
because we served in the in the senate
together
um actually he's not at the center he's
a he's a whatever the other one
he's a houser um
um he said burn baby burn
hurt civil rights movement
which i didn't even know burn baby i
mean i knew i didn't
really i didn't know i know it was like
involved i knew it was from the 60s
and i assumed it was like letting
something burn but it was about like why
it was about
burning down white burning down [ __ ] in
the name of social justice
and he believes it hurt the civil rights
movement which is [ __ ] very
interesting and
it's the thing that i people got mad at
me a couple weeks ago
that liberals don't think that they need
to persuade people
because they're so right how could i
possibly
need to have an effective slogan white
people do have privilege
so what's the problem the problem is i
can tune you out
and i'm gonna but the thing is though
with white privilege i think a lot of
five people did not tune that out i
think they
i think it's a trigger for white people
now because some people like there's
no such thing but like it is a
it's a controversial thing to say you're
benefiting from white privilege it is
right but if you if it makes people
like that that's not a good slogan this
the good slogan is like
oh okay oh but i guess okay so then
let's figure out
is that definition of an effective
slogan
to kind of attention grab and gain like
attention for what you're talking about
or is it for you to
really understand what i'm talking about
i think there's a little bit of both
i think it's to get as many people in
the tent as possible civil rights
movement is a great
title everybody's for
civil rights literally the whitest white
persons for like my civil rights
right and movement it sounds like i
might gain from i'm a white man i might
gain from this
civil rights movement will i be able to
bring my gun
everywhere can i bring my gun to a
maternity ward then i like this
and then movement it just sounds like
meh yeah cool where do i
i'll go with you guys and you follow him
and still people had a friend
i people had a problem with the move
that with
the activity but
what i'm talking about is a persuasive
slogan or
um i had a dream is the maybe the best
right
martin luther king and the mountaintop
i dream of maybe the best because he's
he's basically
not imploring white people to do
anything
it's just like hey take take do what
this what you will
i had a dream and still history again
was bad so i don't think when it comes
to race
in this you don't think there is such a
thing as a good start i don't think so i
think sometimes it's like well [ __ ]
pandering just make it just let's just
be angry about it
you know i don't think i mean we're kind
of proving the point like
in the 60s there were good and bad ones
and it still
yeah i mean the approval rating they
still shot fred hampton
amongst other people so it's like no
only friends that was it
was the only country that was damn they
had a list said freda hampton they
checked it
and then if you look at the signs a lot
of them are so
mild and passive and just like colors
want
equal rights i'm a man how dare you i'm
a man
let me live peacefully like it's so it's
just i feel like
it's hard to say i get i totally
understand your point but i don't think
we've
figured out the right thing so the thing
is white privilege now everybody even
the most
sounds like what you're saying is the
cleveland they should keep the indians
as their names
cause [ __ ] it you're gonna hate us
anyway
just because we're from cleveland um
the thing is though i will say every
white person even in the most literally
white place
has a reaction to the word white
privilege they've heard it
they either believe it or don't you know
whereas some of them
don't yeah i don't i think all these
they're all it's like cancel culture
is it is there
is there a better way to say
because you can like trump mentioned
cancer culture yesterday
in reference to in the cleveland indians
thing like cancer cultures
dog it's the [ __ ] how about minimal
how about the least you can do how about
minimal
consideration i i that's a bad
combination okay but cancer culture
makes you
ma it gives people like i'm against
cancer called all right
it's like but if you go are you against
minimal it's like are you against not
calling
certain groups certain names it's not a
lot
just like it's cancer culture yeah but
what are we can just canceling the word
we're not even canceling it just don't
if you can
don't use it there also everybody on
both sides cancels
everybody the moment the moment people
move a millimeter like when tucker
carlson
i don't know a few weeks ago we talked
about it when i went on the reddit
everyone's like he's cancelled i'm like
yeah
what the hell yeah you're on a taco
carlson subreddit
yeah oh because he he didn't he wasn't
wouldn't let her he didn't he thought
that
people shouldn't he thought a lady was
crazy a crazy person was crazy
um yeah i you might you may be right
i just know
that tone
and messaging are
like the secret sauce of the world yeah
and as much as like [ __ ] it we're done
with that
i don't know obama got elected you know
what i mean like you it's not
impossible and obama wouldn't have
gotten elected with
no no [ __ ] this whole [ __ ] burn
baby burn
why you say like that that's the black
guy's voice
there is a guy in is it the bee gees
i was watching a documentary and there's
a guy
oh they talk about no they cut to new
york in the middle of uh the bts
documentary about
it was blackout and and uh and
and there was that guys black
black brothers used to talk like this
saying this
there was a black guy in the documentary
who talks like this and they stopped
talking like that at a certain point in
the world
like black guys stop you see if you
these long i know it sounds awful this
is a very good idea this is
very funny when you're drinking baby uh
they stopped black guys stopped talking
like that i don't know why
eddie murphy's black guy is basically
that black ivy say baby right
when i was like in the around when i
when my brother got punched in the face
that was like the impression of black
guys yeah
like say my man you can hear when old
comics come to the store and they'll be
like
like the guy well i won't say anything
but yeah he's just like and then i was
like cool kettle whoa
but there really were guys when you see
this guy in the documentary
it's like why how did you talk how the
[ __ ] did you
sound like that i don't know if it's
from the black panthers or what but it's
pretty great i love when people talk one
way and then stop i'm a southern black
woman
no he's that guy's giving it alive he
did a jive
that's so funny um now
okay this is crazy i did did you well
there's a trouble in the vip room
in this winter circle in the winter i
don't know this section
[Music]
my friend devin de la cuenta
is one of the best writers of the daily
show as far as i'm concerned and he
texts me the other day the trouble in
the winner's circle song is so
[ __ ] good it's great crazy great it's
that one
and the um the zanet a [ __ ] i can't
think of it the one that we never play
where are they where are they now she's
a sign she's a real artist
yeah she's amazing um she's going places
um she's on my team i just spun around
in my chair you're on my team
um dude okay fk
fk there you go fka twigs
is suing shia labeouf for
uh physical and emotional abuse and went
to the new york times
i don't know if i guess it's a civil
suit it's a civil suit yeah
um and
he was you know head-butting her
just don't look at men loaded gun next
to the bed so she was scared to get up
and no well he lived in um um
disturbia so you know what i mean you
got it you never got out uh
yeah unknowingly gave her an std yeah
that was a tough one that's really
[ __ ] up yeah and
you know she was like i'm gonna if i'm
gonna out you i'm gonna help me to see
eminem mariah carried him
if i'm going to out you i'm going to
help me too yeah we all got
genital herpes um
yeah uh now
sounded awful what's funny is
something's funny of course
something's always funny um
he'll still get way more girls than me
i know a girl i didn't even know she
dated him
until somehow it came on my that she a
girl i know dated him and i was like
not long ago and it's like you knew ever
you know he's a psycho we all know he's
a psycho by this point
um neil i love how he made this about
you it's all about me my brother got
watched in the face
that's my brother ended disco i could
make it more about me and i won't get
into
because somebody else responded that i'm
not gonna somebody else said that she
got into a she outed
uh somebody else that i know uh said
that
shy and her had a relationship oh oh
well no that's that's been outed
that's not no that's out i know that's
up but i'm not oh you don't want it
i was gonna um
see i'm tasteful even when you think i'm
tasteless there's a level of
tastelessness
that i'm not doing so much um
i just again if a
a guy's a scumbag avoid him
i don't think again yeah i know she
didn't know and there was the honeymoon
period
of that narcissists do when when they
they love it's called love bombing it's
the best term yeah
yeah a lot of a lot of people do that
yeah love bombing where they just like
it's all about you
and you just know it feels like this
is not this can't be sustainable like
you'd have to quit your job
yeah in order to lick my [ __ ] this much
yeah to lick my to go to lift my [ __ ]
from the back
um uh
yeah but she'll you know he'll still get
way more girls than most
even with the gh yeah
they did they say gh that just herpes
they said well
they're definitely the only one right
other than aids i mean like
no awards the class
linger it's like your body it takes a
long time to get rid of them
yeah so you've got to burn them off and
then
i learned this from hunter biden get a
torch um yeah no so
jenna herbie stays around stays around
general ward stays around
so if he's got genital on the title you
don't want it no
um uh but it said in the thing you know
we didn't need to google this part but
killed stray dogs
whoa whoa yeesh
he killed straight dogs that guy the
thing about child abuse he's a like a
loser
you know what i mean like he doesn't
have any he like got
tattoos because he was playing a mexican
gangster
which was a team remember when he would
get in rap ciphers and do
other people's raps he's like a weird
runaway kid
yeah he's like a box cart child yeah and
which
i i get like he's he truly is like
mentally ill
um but dude
people fall for that status [ __ ] have
you ever seen where the store
he behaves very the way he was behaving
in the store was
very weird i don't know i think he was
on the patio i saw him maybe
no he was no he just i mean he would i
don't know this is neither
this doesn't say anything about his i
don't know this is not
totally disparaging but he would go into
one room order drink
go in the or order a drink go in the
belly order drink and like we'd all be
like where the [ __ ] is
oh that's just fame uh you think that it
was yeah that's just like entitlement
but then he would go back and then leave
the amount
like i'd hand him a bill like [ __ ] you
dude with the hell and then he would
look at it
leave go to other just it was oh yeah
he's so weird
she's a really weird mentally which is
not
damaged uh
something it's the kind of guy who
enters rap battles and does other
people's rights like there's something
[ __ ]
whose rap did he do i don't know uh he
will look it up well
well please this is the most interesting
thing
shia labeouf rap um
oh my god you're crazy uh i
no but one stolen rap stolen
stolen rap battle might have been stolen
from a female rap group he just oh he
copied lyrics from a 1999 song please
don't play it
i we we can't right we can't um there
goes your
salary will oh uh yeah that's just
yeah so he just says she just did
something else yeah it's just like a
weird like hey man what are you doing
is this like need for attention sort of
he had a bad he had a legit bad
childhood like that
and that movie's very good which one
honey honey boy yeah oh i thought you
were the one where he was like
mexican he's a no i'm not gonna see that
but congrats on the tattoos good idea
uh oh they were real he got real tattoos
to play a part
you should see the trailer it's terrible
it's laughable it's so bad
i get it i've seen enough bad movies i
can figure out how they made a bad one
he just but like i'm committed and it's
like what do you do
it's just some weird
uninteresting [ __ ] yeah and then the the
and then the abusing women it's like all
right dude you gotta go
i think this is bad for him it's very
bad for him i don't think he's going to
be able to
do it i i don't if but it's not as big
as like mel gibson
no because he's i think he's been weird
long enough that it's not like
like he's kind of grandfathered his way
and like no i get to be weird
right he just if you stay weird long
enough and then still work
[Music]
um but the kisses
you know on the thing it said he had a
quota of kisses a day
and would keep track of how many kisses
you didn't give him
yeah um i might have cage wigs one time
she seemed
like a nice person oh sad
so bless bless
there's also something about you don't
want to date a guy that's that high
status
that's i'm saying that to all the ladies
out there
so don't be attracted hey ladies don't
be attracted to what you're attracted to
um ladies medium status questions you
understand the key to your future
medium status uh you know
a lot of famouses do you
think they all
are a little demented really high status
i'm talking about the real high status
ones
is there a high status normal person
rock's pretty normal
he seems really like spooky to normal
yeah he's just normal he's very normal
um
yeah there's some you just have to make
it it's like i was talking about will
smith last week where it's like his
family was just like hey you're being a
dick
and he was like oh okay and then he just
changed
yeah or stopped being a dick like i
think it's possible
but the problem with this with most
most celebrity problems come from a
either mentally ill part it's just power
and money everyone works for you
no one will say anything negative so you
just
yeah i was watching a doc last night
that's not even on the list called
city so real about chicago it's like a
five-part
series the guy who did hoop dreams
directed it wow and uh yeah
steve james yeah it's good and it's
about the mayoral race
and the anton mcdonald shooting just a
bunch of [ __ ]
but connie's in it and and and
chance is in it and kanye's
basically gone now yeah and chance there
have been some articles recently like
chances
off the reservation also from money and
power and i'm firing you i'm
only going to hire my family and am what
did you hear about chance
there's just a whole lot of suit and his
old manager suing him and
some of it's like the inevitable showbiz
cycle yeah
but then somebody sent me a documentary
and
about what he's just [ __ ] up and not
making he like set a release date before
he had songs
[ __ ] like that where he like dawg no
you gotta not you just gotta make good
[ __ ] and then
release it yeah um it's inevitable
unless you have you almost have to go in
with a plan
to start them yeah like how
i mean rock specifically doesn't have an
entourage because he's like
it just i see what it does to people
what does it do it
everyone works for you so every day is
your birthday
um it's all your birth you first champ
oh god no how do you get out of that
because you can't well you have to
isolate yourself you would just have to
realize that i mean some get married
there's a whole opposite thing which i'm
sure i've talked about which is
a lot of time guys famous people will
get married to [ __ ]
women like i know a lot of guys have
married [ __ ] because they thought oh
this is how people used to treat me
it's so funny and it's like no she's
just a dick
you don't have to over overreact to
everyone being obsequious and nice to
you just
your friends will be nice to you
sometimes
yeah they won't agree with much of what
you said that's why rock keeps you
around
uh well that's what i was going to say
it's like
i'm not nice no so
i think that that's you can't even
i think if people go like neil neil's a
ass kisser like i don't think not from
what i've seen
um i've seen you say really funny things
too yeah yeah oh yeah
uh
oh that was fun there was an article
where
um who's the guy the basketball player
who was who dated iggy azalea
oh yeah kyrie
joking joking uh he has that meme the
question for
me one of the great memes steven steve
yeah nick young
steve nash said he needed to retire
because nick young used to say to him
like man what was it like to just be
able to dominate [ __ ]
like he's still in the league oh
what was it yeah well like what was it
like and i said it to rock and rock
you do this to me every day
[Laughter]
no but i'm not i'm also not like i don't
know
whatever um so
if you're child above you keep getting
chances
he is talented yeah charlotte buff i saw
him on operation
on project greenlight when he was a kid
and i was like that [ __ ] kid is good
i don't i didn't know we even
i don't know anything it was like that
funny you didn't watch it even
nah man i was so good sorry i was 28.
uh but like that kid i was like that
kid's a
i don't know who that kid is but he's
[ __ ] good and then
when you're talented you'll keep getting
chances
and and and you have money and no one's
gonna tell you
that you're full of [ __ ] and
you can do enough [ __ ] that makes you
think you're you can go to a
a he goes to 12-step program and says
like he's
as part of the same he's like i go to as
it's someone who goes to a 12-step
program and
and that becomes you're like well how
bad can i be
yeah i go to a 12-step program it's like
oh you that shit's bouncing right off
you
you've got the ted you've got the
necklace you've got the debt you've got
all the [ __ ] but
coins got all the gifts [ __ ] coins
it doesn't mean it's just cover for some
people yeah
um yeah i feel bad for fk twigs
and she's really her album was [ __ ]
great yeah and
um and she was nice when i
met her and that's all i can say
about that brother got punched in the
face um
yes um my brother got punched my brother
is the reason
disco is is where it is today
well let's dog watch it
[Music]
that song could be shorter yeah the
reverb at the end
you know you know well get in maybe on
the second doc watch
get in late leave early that's it
that's the whole song okay that's all we
need we're guys what we're do
we have a mandate here we have a
movement where we're going to shorten
that
shorten the songs it's a movement
room 2806 the accusation
which you're watching it's so
interesting uh the french
the frenchies it's interesting to see
how
i mean i know it didn't the it's
basically about the
head of the imf i this is a
recent story that i couldn't believe
how little i remembered in 2011 i
remember dominic strauss khan
as a guy and i remember the trial
in a very i remember the whole thing in
a
very ambient way i don't i didn't have
specific memories of any of it i
remember
he assaulted a black immigrant i didn't
even
i was like oh right everything was like
okay yeah yeah dominick rouse khan like
so he was a french dude head of imf
assaulted uh
made in a hotel in new york yes that's
just for whoever doesn't understand yes
um it just was so funny to me how
the french were like ah he's passionate
the funniest dude crusty like keith
richards kind of looking dude yeah
there were five different french guys
saying in thick french accents basically
like why can't
i touch a woman's [ __ ] he was like you
don't want your president
do you have a passion it was like oh god
damn
it i guess i guess i
want him no i don't want him to have
passion no how about that
it was the first time i said i want to
[ __ ] her
i thought about that yeah i did too
games um
it was the first time i was like wow
nypd
i like the way you operate it was the oh
yeah
what episode are you in oh no i know
it's i know when the guy's high fived i
was like something's wrong
yeah but i'm on episode
three ish so
what i mean though is that there's it
was just so rare
to see in a documentary
in a sexual allergy allegation case
because
yeah being really supportive yeah i know
there's like
there's something going on i know i
don't i haven't finished the documentary
because it's
episodic on netflix but i don't think
the cops were in on it no i don't think
they wrote it on it without but i do
think
it just was uh they also wanted to get
him kind of you know
and i liked how that person said you
think being a celebrity with cops is
always gonna go over well but sometimes
the cops are like
oh oh you think about it you think
you're venomous yeah like that's what
dave calls the real celebrity treatment
yeah it's like now with him it happens
one out of a hundred times and he's like
see
one out of a thousand see this is how
they really when it's like yeah but what
about the 90
999 other times um but
yeah it was weird to see the opposite
side of it and i don't know it so it's
just it's really an interesting look at
um infidelity and sexual assault and how
that's being taken in the french side
that was really fast what was funny yeah
i
i wrote a thing down um
it would it there i don't know it's it
would be of good
update feature of a french guy going
like what you're saying
that like a french lawyer going like no
so you're saying i cannot
and then be like no no you can't he's
like oh please
with your pedestrians yeah um
it was the last episode was great okay i
mean
i thought every episode was really good
they're really well made and yeah
i you know what i don't like that i
can't stand this thing they do
with the [ __ ] times coming in they
did them wrong they did the graphics
backwards
they did they try to do what the bowls
documentary yeah
but they did them they would leave the
date would leave the screen
i was i was watching and going like what
where would this make sense
because i don't it doesn't you know i
don't i don't think that's the way the
french
do dates it would it was like leave
the left side of the front it would it
would leave the left side of the frame
and the frame would be empty and then it
would come up on the right side
and it would but it would be the past it
was and then they would play the 911
call and they'd be like one day before
the 901 call and then they'd play a
snippet of it i'm like
were there two 9-1-1 calls yeah it was
like
i couldn't tell if they were saying he
actually this is the second person he
just
that's where you get into like do you do
the video reverse
like you know what i mean like there's
hack
that's i know it's just a or don't play
the audio when you're saying
one game before the audio right but it's
relevant to the
what they were doing i don't know
anyways but it was it's interesting i
can't wait to
i can't wait to finish it you're gonna
love that ending okay um
uh all right alabama snake
did you see this i did i watched it when
you told me
some of it i gave me the willies it was
really
dark it was crazy i can't even explain
what it was it was it was like a cult
the guy it was there's like snake
charmers
in but in america like in alabama it's
called alabama snake
they're just uh they're just christian
extremists they're like extreme
christians they're like
basically it's that it's a level beyond
the holy ghost
yeah like you do the holy ghost and it's
like all right well can you just grab
snakes
and play with rattlesnakes no yeah it's
saying there's like a
line out of the bible yes
that
but what about snakes though is the line
they spoke to
uh that scared the [ __ ] out of me
i won't get into it anymore specifically
it's a hell of a truth ain't it
was on oh hbo hulu
i thought you were saying that about the
alabama season i was like no
no this is truthful uh no it's a
documentary called it's a hell of a
truth ain't it
and uh it's a prison documentary
okay but the
the way it's done is really good because
they the
prisoners kind of made the shorts cute
but it's not that cute it's not like i
made a short it's
it's it's that it's not sentimental like
that
but they do the woman director did cut
together a version
she cut she put like an hour together
and then
showed it to them and then they show
them watching it
and then being like do i talk like that
like
that shit's cute but then they were like
well what should the story be
right it's interesting it's like a
little meta them
trying to filmmake or is it they they
all made it
and then we're just watching they
they're trying to film like the woman
sort of like
them i think they all filmed and did
interviews
and then the woman took the female
director
took the footage and did some animated
sequences
and and then there's cut to the
interviews because they're
it's the cameraman's not a prisoner i'm
assuming so it's not like
it's not locked up it's no it and it
doesn't seem rudimentary it's not it's
like well made
um yeah it's good
and it's just a good new idea um
bgs of course i uh
i call them the teethies because their
teeth
are so giant wait the bj's
foot of the beaches barry gibb
oh my i can see it from here uh
yeah i mean the t what i was saying is
and they were
from nice teeth from the start they're
all too big
all of them and but they all had them
from
the jump yeah this wasn't veneers and
what i kept thinking is imagine how much
louder they could sing without those
giant teeth in the way
those giant sound baffling teeth did you
ever do
like a decade very stylistic thing like
this feather i would love to do that no
did you ever get uh
bob i mean kurt cobain
and before that i had like the michael j
fox mullet really yeah
there i don't i saw one picture of him
one time and it made me laugh so hard it
like
i but i saw it like in the late 80s i
was like i cannot believe my hair was
like this
um yeah um
and the the great thing about
like i said they have stories about how
their songs are written
which never happens and then they had
noel gallagher from oasis talking about
being in a
band with your brothers which is like
yep all right this is good
and it's another thing timberlake talks
about
them musically and when you hear
the way noel gallagher i think noah liam
the the
songwriter one um the one who doesn't
sing very much or now he does but
the way musicians can talk about music
you just you just like you can't talk
like this
like they they know like timberlake says
they're all of the bg's
vocals could be horn parts [ __ ] know
that you know what i mean like that's
not a thing i even would
know to think he's like yeah funk
infused beats
uh they so
[ __ ] like that noel gallagher said it's
like having
um uh it's like when you have
when it's your brother when it's your
family that's an a sound you cannot
recreate you literally can't make that
sound unless you were born in the
they have one of the jonas brothers so
like that [ __ ] was interesting
they didn't have any bad interviews
basically um
and there and they're one of the groups
that was able to culturally
appropriate kind of
and black people had to [ __ ] with it
just like
ah yeah this [ __ ] is nice yeah like um
or it's like when average white band
it's like that's not perfect
just say call yourself average white
band yes casey the sunshine band average
white band and bg's like black hall of
fame
come on in come on come on like no can't
say [ __ ] like
you wrote what when it's hard to believe
that a white person
wrote that [ __ ] some of those bass lines
for you
michael mcdonald i feel like these yeah
it's like so smooth
so when you the average white man you're
like they're not white
they're not they can't be white that's a
joke name that's a joke name
button sure enough and they're funny
because that name is hilarious yeah it's
funny yes
agreed um that was like you know what's
funny when i was young
no one knew because it's not like today
i don't think
younger people would understand but no
one for a long time knew vanilla ice is
not black before
91 no when he came out
at first like when his song just played
on the radio a lot of people yeah for
like
they're just like yeah he's even though
it's like vanilla eye because you don't
see a photo of people
immediately back then it was hard to get
a photo what
you have to get a magazine you have to
go to a store
get to go but you have to do work
yes it took an hour if you wanted to see
what vanilla eyes looked like
it was going to take you and it was like
an average will search
well will you look up uh
staying alive lyrics well you the other
girls
[ __ ] barry came up with uh
new york times no that he came up with
uh the producer it was one of those
things where the producer
was the bg's manager and he
optioned the rights to the move to the
store the new york magazine article that
the movie became based on
so it was like all in how he signed
travolta to like
three movies for a million bucks wow
really and it was ended up being
sorry fever grease and a bomb but who
cares
yeah um and i do but so
barry gibbs on the phone he's like yeah
i have the guy's like you got any titles
and he's like
i got uh staying alive and
night fever wow because those are signs
right those are the song titles and he's
like he goes i gotta have saturday in it
so i'll
i'll make it saturday night favor and
you just say sorry fever
is 70 million times better than night
fever
yes it's crazy he said night fever
sounds like a porn and he's
absolutely right um night fever
go it's the beginning well uh
there was a lyric that i wanted to tell
you can tell by the way i use my walk
i'm a what you're i'm a woman's man no
time to talk
this guy [ __ ] so much
that he doesn't even have time to talk
i don't have time to talk because i [ __ ]
so many women
i'm on my way to [ __ ] women if i see you
i'm putting away seven or eight women
yeah women warm music loud women warm
uh and you may look the other way we can
try to understand the new york times
effect
on man i don't think that's the right
lyric yeah it is the new york times can
make
a man no that's what that's what i'm
saying i don't think there's anytime's
effect on man
i don't yeah these are the wrong lyrics
uh go to genius go to genius
effect that's
even better now yeah the failing near
time the failing new york times effect
that's weird they're bad lyrics whether
you're a brother or whether you're a
mother you're staying on this
mandela effect feel the city breaking
and everybody's shaking
the rhyming ones are kind of yeah i like
the new york times
we will get low if you told me that
there's a line we will get low inside
fever
well now i get i get low and i get high
but i can't get either i really try yeah
got the wings of heaven on my shoes i'm
a dancing man i just can't live oh wow
this is hilarious wings of heaven on my
shoes
but every but they have so the stories
of writing these songs is great
writing rhymes and um
uh it's the document it's great god
bless the documentary
do you have uh ownership in the
documentary i don't you but it's
exciting i watched it twice
oh my gosh i watched it trayvon sent me
a link and then i wat so i watched it
like last wednesday and then when it
aired saturday i was like let's go again
wow let's run it run it again you know i
can't watch a movie twice
ever it's impossible
it's torture to me if i want like good
fellas i it has to be
years years in between where i forget
a scene or two so you've never been in
the phase
where you're just watching a movie over
and over impossible and i don't
understand how people are that's right
oh really i can't understand what you're
doing so what happens is so i see a
movie i don't understand
you uh i see a movie
and if i watch it again my brain is
constantly tormenting me with what the
next scene is gonna be well
and i saw i cannot get into it because
i'm just like yeah then he does this
this and then
it just won't let me
get into it so it's just constantly
reminding me
of the next scene it's very it's not
good
um some people watch me you know barry
gibb likes to sound out lyrics
what's that
[Music]
he doesn't they have the session
of how deep is your love
[Music]
there's a i have the michael jackson
when thriller was called
starlight oh it's different lyrics
but there are people that like sia
played on howard stern
she wrote diamonds the rihanna song
and she does like the she would sound
out lyrics
but i don't think it's a good way to
write lyrics because you end up with
like
i'm a woman's i mean yeah i got dancing
i think you got to write poetry the only
way to do is write poetry and then see
if it matches what's a what's the movie
you've seen the most
do you have like a fave serendipity
trainspotting
goodfellas
there's a documentary about radiohead
called meeting people is easy that i
used to just watch incessantly
really yeah uh that's so funny
mullany watched an incessantly do i
didn't know that he told me that like a
month ago and i was like dude i
i it's but also if you
there's [ __ ] in it that like is
indelibly
it's about like the drudgery of the road
especially when you're a sad band sad
kind
and so it's about like the walking to
photo shoots
and like that's not fun they never show
you the photo
they just show them like where are we
going no we've got to
tower lobby floor and they're on the
elevator and whatever
um and yeah
i think the older you get you kind of
can't do it anymore
but i watch trainspotting like
40 times many people see 40 times
um that's so funny yeah it's a very good
movie
train spot is amazing i've watched the
only movie i could do that with okay
there's one it's just shaft
but not the old one no the sam jackson
one and buster rhymes one
the sam jackson christian bale it's so
weird from like
2002 yeah i think buster's in that is he
yeah that one's very good
you should know you've seen it more time
no i just i just haven't i haven't
watched it
uh jeff jeff wright's in it christian
bale yeah that's the one
that one i can watch that's funny that i
don't know why that one yeah but ryan's
played rasan i don't know
because oh rasson uh
it's funny that scott rudin directed it
because he's like one of the best
directors in the world and that's not a
good movie
it's a good movie actually that's the
only it just
is it's it's that really good
i i don't know it's just a good it's an
easy good movie like
pulpy like that movie the brothers or
something where it's like we're going
downtown to take care of this and then
they cut to
it's like watching kind of it's like uh
where is he at
that type of [ __ ] it's like uh what's
your favorite or something
hasn't the negotiator is not a good
moment well you know what i mean that
90s kind of um
what is it the die hard yeah well
there's something to figure out
and we have to get to the bottom of it
that kind of thing like
i would say die hard three is bet the
new york die hard is better
than zeus the one jesus zeus
i don't know uh with sam jackson the one
that's in new york
yeah i think it's in it's yeah that
one's good that one's so funny because
so you know how that's the one where
they make him go say like i hate news
yes
so i was watching it on twitter i
already improv
uh so i was watching on tv and uh
uh they censor it so it just says i hate
people
and the people like hey hey man don't
say that what the
[ __ ] and it's this group of dudes coming
and it's like he's like
and then sam jackson's like what are you
doing with that it's
so funny because it just says i hate
people that's
excellent it's excellent and i'm gonna
watch that
over and over but on youtube
shall we and then tiger woods america's
son espn
uh documentary and
i it got really good reviews and then it
was more about
his meaning to black people which is a
minimal yes but why and
how it came to be how they went from
and just like the pj tour used to have
11 black people now it's
then had one when he was on it and now
it's got four
and they and being and tiger woods used
to be more militant where
they said is there anywhere you want to
win when especially goes yeah i want to
win at the masters because of how they
treat blacks
you're like all right [ __ ] like that
where they
footage i'd never seen before yeah um
that that's good
so that's coming your way guys well
let's do some letters
[Music]
literally
[Music]
oh he's trying to send us some messages
oh he's like
well well well okay he really
[ __ ] chunked he truncated it
you've got mail um hey neyland banks
long time feeler your conversation about
the word [ __ ] i boarded this out to
nobody but the algorithm selling me [ __ ]
on facebook
uh and neil kept referring to the
entomology of the word
the study of the origin of word is
etymology
entomology is the study of insects you
idiot
had to drop a line word nerds matter
keep being awesome
then he said peace which now he's cool
all of a sudden he says [ __ ] like
peace because he's smokes doops
um oh this is about you so when you read
it okay
hey feely and thinky
okay thank you
uh lstnr that's naz
oh wow he's he's really trying to send a
message
last episode you guys were talking about
how ever since
taking the liquor of the gods you kept
seeing and hearing ayahuasca references
everywhere
what you are experiencing is called the
batter meinhof phenomenon played bader
meinhof
no it's bad of mine off it's german yeah
you're right
that was a trap yeah okay entomology
[ __ ]
expert uh vader mine hop and there's a
bunch of movies about it
the bottom i have complex is not so much
about
that so this guy's wrong no no this the
phenomenon is different
oh got it the battle mind
so it's got a it's got a complex and a
phenomenon
it's that it's that good it was about
these like people
it's a movie and a tv show it's because
someone
someone heard about the bottermeinhof
terrorist group
the territory
or the frequency all right so frequency
illusion that's the phenomenon
frequency illusion yes um
once somebody's been noticed then every
instance of the thing is noticed
leading to belief that it's high
frequency of occurrence
a form of selection bias great
i like it never suffer
well really killing it goodbye
greetings clinically depressed
middle-aged white men here my wife is a
tough-as-nails smoke show
my wife's the toughest nail smoke show
who for more than 20 years has hunkered
down in the foxhole with me and taken
everything depression can hurl at us
in particular since any medication that
works for me also obliterates my libido
she's had to endure over a decade of
essentially a sexual marriage
this was until this past week i don't
know
what switch got flipped to me but
there's some real animal type [ __ ] going
on around here
several times a day sometimes sometimes
in hilariously inappropriate contexts
etc etc needless to say my wife has been
over the moon about the change
she's a smoke show and she's over the
moon here's my pickle
although of course i really hope this is
a permanent change given my history it's
reasonable to think that it's probably
temporary if so
then we really need to make the most of
it now
uh i'm pretty conventional on my taste
and frankly
i'm just happy to be [ __ ] but my wife
has always had more of a little freak in
her and i'm pretty sure that
secretly there's some truly appalling
[ __ ] she'd like to get up to
find by me i really want her to get to
do anything she wants to do
but the residue of her deeply religious
childhood means there is no chance
she'll tell me what she wants if uh
if the if if if the has any
feeling that what she wants is shane
she [ __ ] up uh i need some help and
soon my own
inclination is just to enjoy what we're
doing while it lasts and she certainly
seems to be thrilled just as things are
but i know i'll feel terrible if i
return to the state of sexual catatonia
and and then it seems to me that she
regrets
vis-a-vis unfulfilled desires desires
yeah desires
so he's saying what should he do if you
suspect you're not fulfilling
your wife's needs i have an idea that
i've always
had that i think that you will not like
bianca but he's
he says he's saying like should i what
how do i get my wife to admit she likes
she wants to do [ __ ] because she's got
so much religious shame tied up
it'll be hard to get her to admit it
here's an idea of i've had
yeah tell me have a questionnaire oh
yeah it's
great but the problem is i can't it's
perfect for him
because it's his wife and yeah yeah for
sure but the
first thing i do if i hand a woman a
questionnaire
she's gonna go how many people have you
done this to and then i gotta tell
her a lot um
but it it if in terms of long term
it's highly effective she would be
happier in the long run
but the problem is that questionnaire is
gonna also have a another page staple to
it which is going to be like
a sex schedule and
what we're doing when what freaky [ __ ]
we're doing that's the problem it's the
slippers
1 30 i'm hanging out the window [ __ ]
then you're gonna start i just feel like
the worksheet it's gonna be a slippery
slope free it's a worksheet for
everything
but you're not wrong but what i will say
what if i didn't do the worksheet i
think asking
i think jimmy carr should do it why jim
don't bring jimmy
because he's married and he i know he's
listening but she's satisfied i'm sure
um jimmy
would it shock you if she wasn't he
wears robes
that's a great point anybody who wears
robes
is [ __ ] at least three days a week
and well well um
he's got that robe dick um
yeah i mean yeah so i if you're a
married man or you're in a committed
relationship
you've got to make the questionnaire and
leave everything
make everything available because the
thing about sex
is if you're into something you assume
everyone's into it
and if you're not like i've had i'll
have sex with a woman
and one one woman will be like
yes butt stuff and then another woman
will be like
why would you even pitch that do you
know what i mean
that other woman sounds uptight right
because you're not a square
i'm not square i'm not they don't again
they don't say why would you
again i don't but i'm saying it like i
don't know what i have no
idea what you're into i'm just guessing
yeah and if i guess wrong i'm going away
for a long long time upstate
uh so okay yes
what if you are you so
dead set on certain sexual acts that you
you kind of
like again
with a woman i'm it's not even about
butt stuff it's about like
it's about
a a menu of like don't forget all this
stuff's available
you we can do all this stuff so i'm not
saying you want it tonight i'm just
saying in general
are there things that you would like to
do that
yeah maybe they're not comfortable yeah
like and i'm if it's a
if to make someone say like i want you
to spit on me is weirder than just like
a box that just says spit oh or
butt stuff whatever you again i'm just
you're like
you know what would be better no i'm
just thinking about because i'm like
but what would be better
is the reverse have options say pick the
ones you don't want
so i don't have to really say i want
butt stuff
i feel like that would make women more
comfortable interesting just say what
you don't want and
you have to opt out and the other one is
just like opt out of being a
organ donor yeah yeah it's just like
just
don't don't look no nothing yeah don't
look at me just do if it if i have
my feet yeah no feet no this but then
the
other stuff maybe she wants or maybe
she's cool with but doesn't want to say
some girls don't want to be weird
freaky dickies yeah so i feel like
i think you're right then you're into
a mount no come on what do you have
just whenever uh slapping
choking whoa whoa this is on your list
i know but slap if i sl i've never this
is the thing you can't explain to women
if you want me to slap you on the ass
why
wouldn't i think you want me to slap you
on the
face
why why is spanking anything
no but you're equating all parts of the
body to like
pain pain on the butt the butt can take
a beating your face
i mean face is kind of rude i'm not
saying women don't like it i'm just
saying
all of it's i mean it's all rude right
but
me being wanting like [ __ ] is rude
just called violence um if i want my ass
left when i'm
god mom turn this off if i want my ass
left when i'm
riding you that's different than
an open-handed slap i would have not
that i would have in the face
i get you but i know people i've slept
with women who
wanted to be slapped in the face but and
guess what they wanted before that
to be slapped in the ass i know but why
not just not assume that
i'm not but what i'm saying is you're
saying what's the difference
no no i'm not saying what's the
difference what i'm saying is if as a
guy
i don't understand why you want me to
slap you on the ass to begin
i've n i have no desire to be slapped in
any way i want all pleasure across the
board right
so just the idea of any sort of
whipping slapping i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you doing so i don't
even understand the logic of it you
don't clean it so if i sleep with one
girl
who once gets slept on the ass and then
i sleep with another girl who wants to
get slept in the ass
and face the next time i sleep with a
girl
and i say no no if i say you want to get
slapped and they go yeah
that's where you get into the opting in
is more
i'm trying to be sex positive with the
sex toy
sex sex sex
section here section here there's
nothing else we can say about it that's
the section here yeah um okay
yeah i've never [ __ ] a woman but i
think it's not
i don't recommend it it's not for it's
not for everybody
over hype uh um
uh yeah it's just that's the difficulty
is everyone thinks that they're
no one very few women just go no you go
even you who's into things that other
people will go like
when i say slap spit you're like i was
my visceral reaction was mostly to you
saying
slap on the ass why do you want to get
something else and not in the face
that's kind of
weird like i could i you can make some
arguments right that's all the core of
yes but what i'm saying is some people
want both and somebody want to be choked
and somebody want to be spit on
some people want yeah they want you to
steal their credit card and run it run
up
a thousand dollars for the debt not a
problem with your
moist mouth not i bring i will bring
a tablespoon know that
um okay so you i have a question though
why do you need it to be so like a
standardized
thing because i don't want a name no i
don't that thing of like let's figure it
out
no no i don't i've never
that's that's why i like schedules i
just don't
i don't want to figure it out it's
custom
women like customs and and pageantry
more than men do
i want to know what you want so i can do
it effectively
and not like everybody just i don't i
don't want to go to jail
yeah i don't want you to be weirded out
i want to go to the
edge of what you want and then go no
further
so that's the your heart's in the right
it's always in the right place goodbye
you've got me my spirit padre
uh and mantre wondering if you've had
the chance to listen ezra klein's new
pod with michael pollan
i have listen to it today more
specifically pollen's assertion
that recreational use of psychedelics
aren't as useful meant
mental health wise without a therapist
before during and after wondering your
opinions on that given your recent usage
of different settings
maybe we can discuss on the iowa's cast
did you think it is uh useful or
completely controlled
do you think it is only useful in a
completely controlled mental health
care setting uh would it be more helpful
with more or less guidance
what nank think what picking thing some
are in cartoon
um i yeah i don't that's
what that was the i realized that you
just
it there's got to be uh
with ayahuasca especially it's really
potent yeah and so you just have to be
around
someone who really knows what they're
doing and has a
protocol um how would you advise people
after having done
a few just go with somebody
how do you go with somebody that go to
like a church
somebody with or somebody with a
active practice where they they do it
and they have a group they have like a
regular group or they have a schedule
usually it's like these people have
twice a month
weekend excursions and then there's also
just go to peru or brazil and they're
all
pros what about um you've done it with
friends and you've done it with
a bunch of strangers what do you notice
the difference
i well i'm very to myself just because i
think that's the way to do it um
the the what michael ballen was talking
about
was having a supervised
shroom trip a heroic dose five six grams
with a therapist to talk to if you want
uh the problem is there are
not many of them who are easy like i
had one schedule yeah and
i was like what this lady
what's the problem she just wasn't
didn't quite
something about it seemed to
[Music]
fly by night the person that i was gonna
do it with
so i just i backed out um
and that's me i'll do i don't give a
[ __ ] you really do
so this lady you know how dusty she had
to be
um uh so yeah do it
in a in a in a with ayahuasca do it in
an environment
with a shaman who you intrinsically
the shaman that i went to with bijan
and catherine the first night i was like
this guy's a [ __ ] goofball
right and i mean the guy we used was a
absolute goofball but then the
the guy i went to um
the first night i thought it was a
goofball and then second night you were
like i was like this guy's
legit yeah um and
it's basically just like a feeling
absolutely
i mean absolute goofball uh it's
basically just a feeling like do i
feel i don't do i trust
do i trust this person to to kind of
think of them as a therapist or think
think of this somewhere between a doctor
and a therapist
and but the problem is kind of tour
guide's not official enough
it would be more like a safari guide
safari good yeah like this guy knows a
shitload about animals
and like lives out here and can be like
now we gotta go
we gotta go and why why are you
explaining birds
yes exactly um so
but we tend to think of these people as
drug dealers
who people that have
dealt with drug dealers our whole lives
in drug interactions oh yeah
so who are they people i just was like i
don't feel like i was
what
hey man like melanie's joke about like
smoking weed hitting on our girls and
smoking part of the thing we bought from
them
it's just kind of a weird that was so
that's so funny that that was
like standard kind of was standard um
now because delivery services is more
just like here you go
thank you goodbye back then it was just
like
you know jeff yeah man how do you know
him and then you gotta talk to them
35 minutes um can i use your bathroom
and you're like oh god
he'll never leave um do you think you do
you think
what did you think about his his power
yeah
him saying that do psychedelics he's
right he didn't
at least on the ezra's podcast he didn't
talk enough about
it no he didn't talk about iowa he
mentioned that there's ayahuasca
churches um
for what's legal uh
the the yeah the the
heat this time about mushrooms talking
about cyber selling so
psilocybin uh cypress hill whatever you
want to call it
uh cyber talent um
so yeah so i would say i would rather
do iowa the next time i do ayahuasca
it's
the only time i do ayahuasca now it's
going to be with a real pro
who's a real pro the guy in the face
or the other dude not the guy we went to
no not the goof ultimately not the good
ball but the
i don't still want to say their names
but the no but the other
yeah the other yeah i've only been to
two would you do it
with a would you go like uh travel yeah
peru yeah but not that i don't want to
walk
just carry me i don't want that's
getting a picture of vanilla ice was
like getting to an ayahuasca trip
in brazil um so yeah goodbye
[Music]
interesting question what's the what's
good neil and binky i'm a 39 year old
white male and i listen to a lot of rap
from young until now it's been the
largest and most consistent musical
musical genre i'm cool with it thanks
bro
most people that know me are cool with
it it's been an
ever evolving what year is this uh
is this 1985 it's been an ever evolving
process of what it means to be a white
man
a privilege who listens to the work of
people of color who live differently
by the way black people i hope you're
happy with
white privilege and now you have to
listen to white preambles
you did you did this to yourself you had
it too good you asked for too much and
now you have to deal with [ __ ]
white preambles ugh uh
work dude i listen to everything each
week i'm putting up music on my phone
with thursday night being the high point
for new music
the latest ripples that my partner is
about to give birth to our first child
any day now
outside of a wild curve ball we will be
having a little white girl
first what's your advice as i continue
to listen to the music
i like now with growing impressionable
ears
uh who i'm told can glom onto a word and
repeat it without warning there's a lot
of problematic [ __ ] for a little white
girl repeat
second biggs how do i as a father who
likes listening to music where mostly
men say super foul sentences about women
explain to a more developed brain that
what's being said
i think it means less developed that
what's being said is just part of the
package deal of rap
and that we should never think uh any of
this is okay
if she's confronted with it in uh real
life interactions or medium
of art in her orbit um asking now
because who knows where any of us will
be in
two or twelve years
um what do you think
[Music]
i don't know if you have to say anything
to her interesting you're
you did grow up around custody though
yeah we had a cuss day so
i'm from a different part different side
of the tracks
but um i i feel like a lot of this [ __ ]
you just get the streets teach you
the streets aren't going to teach it
someone's going to teach her which is
like her friends
what i'm saying i think let's say from
age one to twelve
what should he do should he not listen
to it around her
no i think it's fine because in the end
like
i am really appreciative of all the
different types of music my parents
played
for me you just by the way it wasn't
wasn't hip-hop wasn't misogynist wasn't
what was what your parents played what
are you telling me that
i i unequivocally am telling you that
yeah there's no way your parents played
you like
hardcore hip-hop before the age of 12.
my mom played me nwa and
like to quote you who
my mom played me um what is it i see
dead on arrival was it that
is that the adam album when he has a the
death tag
and she explained every single song to
me and i was five and she was like how
old were you
five and what time did child service
show up what what song
uh yeah no vaseline explain me that
explain me oreo
explain me all these songs so i'm a
little little all right i'm wrong i was
wrong
you're very
i believe that it happened but i i don't
think
i don't think that's good parenting oh
that's good i saw new jack city in the
theater
i was single digit i saw that i agree
with
uh every all those jews
all all the black the blacks the black
gang series
i thought straight out of politics
poetic justice um
no i saw them all with my mom at the
theater so i don't [ __ ] know
i'm not a good i mean it makes you
cooler
i'm not a good gage because i think yeah
i don't think custody was
great because they i decosted feels
experimental
it was completely and but in a good way
like i don't to me it seems like well
this is a thing you that you can't do
but you can do it today and then you'll
remember not to do it the rest of the
day and we did and it was fine but what
it
the problem was there was times i let i
let it fly yeah i did i did football uh
when yeah
football player did you did it at the
wrong time did you stay at the wrong
time
and because they had the wrong down uh
cousins at school and then you know i
got in trouble a few times so i think
i don't know i just i think a lot of the
time
parents are like what do i allow my kid
to
know about the world but kids pick up a
lot more just even in elementary school
how much [ __ ] do kids bring
but i think it's you're better off
tom papa one time said his daughter had
just turned 13 or 14.
he's coming tom popping he goes he goes
yeah now it's a thing where
uh we set rules and she has to figure
out ways to break them
that's a good time like that's the that
um but that's the that that's fine
i even i just think like if you can
avoid i think
part of a parent's job is to prolong
childhood for as long as possible
without being weird
no i for sure like innocence and don't
don't
don't be violent don't yell don't be you
know what i mean like don't
show graphic [ __ ] but then as long as
you can
but then my stepdad was really into like
classes
all types of rock from the 80s and i
would listen to that and like their
lyrics aren't
it's all about [ __ ] underage girls
yeah so
your stepdad was trying to get it ew
don't worry that's so gross
you said ooh but no moving on
to him bowing to the one wall
rose there's like five neil weirdo i
didn't know you're seeing my twitter
um so no so i i think
honestly for i'm just gonna be real it's
unless you're
like my mom explaining to me lyrics
sorry mom she's gonna be mad that i told
that sorry
but unless you're like my mom doing that
kind of hard to retain as a kid
i don't see do you know what i mean i
feel like you can get away with
listening to your [ __ ] yes and it not be
like why did
she he say you know i don't know
i can i would just say play radio
versions if you i i think it's worth
editing them hearing the genre
yeah like it's worse but i think some
songs are just not
no not i mean it seems like they're all
like it's all about whops
um and they're not even in a if it's an
edited version yeah you're right i think
it's a good
dude because it's worth hearing but it's
just not
you just don't want okay we did it we
did it it took us a while
and we implicated a lot of people but we
got there
and we're all better off goodbye
um okay this is where we get into the uh
expertise business
okay um you've got mayonnaise hey neil
and bianca lstn er last week you guys
were responding to an email from a dude
who pretty much
said i'm just as funny as you are and
even though you've left a historic
influence on sketch comedy you're not
better than me
the dude obviously has some self-esteem
issues to work out that's all
of the email anyhow i completely agree
with you that some people are born with
comedic talent comedic
uh that's just the way their brain works
it's like how
not all of us have the mindset to become
a nobel prize-winning scientist
or a legendary athlete but since
groups like anti-vaxxers climate change
deniers trumpers anti-masters
um uh have become more popular
over the last decade it seems people
believe more and more that
reading a few blog posts on the subject
makes their opinions just as credible as
a trained professional
this movement away from established
knowledge has been referred to as the
death of expertise
it's the book i mentioned last week uh
it's called the death of expertise
um i think it's fair to say that you're
an expert on your craft and it must be
frustrating for anyone
to think that they have an understanding
of comedy equal to yours because they've
taken a few improv
classes it's just as stupid as somebody
saying they could operate on a patient
because they've taken a cpr seminar
good metaphor do you feel like there uh
has been a similar death of expertise in
the comedy community in the last few
years
or have people always looked at comedy
as something anyone could do with just a
little practice
uh yes there's more there's another
letter
um uh
sort of the same thing i just like that
they called me a
i represent a newer generation of
comedian oh i didn't even say that
i know i'm not a community yeah so
someone else asks you know you know
you respect comedians enough and know
that they never
do that yes like i'm also coming and
honestly
a lot of people just put on their resume
i've had multiple
managers be like just do stan just get
phil if he's doing something like
you don't understand yeah i'm not gonna
do that
it would be better helpful for your
career i'm like dude i'm
like i could not look at myself in the
mirror it's a different someone who
like goes hunting a few times and
someone who lives in a tree
that's the difference between people
that do stand up sometimes
and people that do it all the time so uh
my question is how this is the other way
so you blended them
i know i think i think the whole work
verse talent debate misses a huge
component of what makes a sexual
comedian
that is obsession every comedian is
obsessed with comedy you're the kind of
people who will memorize every line from
delirious and watch the comedy store
documentary six times over and over
and while you're on stage not only are
you chasing laughs you're chasing a
particular kind of laugh
this is all very true uh the question is
how would an obsessed want to be
comedian figure out whether they've got
enough talent to keep pushing through
failure
and rejection in order to develop their
craft at what point should it be game
over
then there's at least one more whoa
this is the one that i wanted to talk
about um
[Music]
uh hey neil bianca i had the below draft
queued up
until you eviscerated that poor bastard
at the end of this week's show
who just wants to believe he's a comedy
he's a comedy class or two away from
dress to kill
which if you hold that up as the best
comedy special ever
bless you i mean it's not don't get me
wrong it's
got some [ __ ] great bits in it but
please uh obviously beginner stand-up
classes won't replace the lonely
childhood and yet
neil is made out to be the [ __ ]
because some people believe they are a
golf lesson away from being tiger woods
still i narcissistic me am different and
i
can't help my armchair self all right so
this is he'd already written this
hey neil and bianca big fan of the
podcast and of three mikes three mike's
an absolute masterpiece
i've been listening to you for the last
year or so you always mention how hard
stand-up is and then i watch the
showtime
comedy room series which again this
guy's i think he's british
oh um series you recommended and saw you
guys talk about how hard comedy is
and i sometimes listen to pete holmes
you make it weird you made it weird
uh where he talks to other comics about
how hard standup is
with all day respect if the goal in
standup is now
doing a great one-hour special per year
it doesn't seem that hard
it's the sculpting of material in front
of strangers and humiliating yourself at
open mic lotteries and bombing new
material
and being competitive with super unhappy
people and traveling to crappy places
that seem so hard
not making people laugh for an hour i'm
guessing
given that you've said that there are
only like 250 people in the world
who can do what you do you think it is
pretty hard i kind of want to bet on
that
like 50 grand to a good cause no i'm
keeping the money
says if you give me 10 weeks wow no
put me in front of a fair crowd and give
me three nights like you pros get
i could write perform a median comedy
store regular hour special
i don't know how you would judge success
i'll leave it up to you
if there's one thing i find really
honorable from listening to your podcast
you have an innate sense of fairness
thank you sir i wish bianca did as well
i'm 37 was an options trader for 10
years then quit to start a sports
gambling startup
so i've spent my career in betting and
i'm pretty sure i have an edge
let me guess if you'd be let me know if
you'd be interested in a little wager
from a big fan oh
thank you you have to do it i
i wouldn't put an audience through it oh
come on
they are put through do you think an
audience is going to sit for an amateur
for an hour
if we if we say yeah
dude if you say it's a bet they're not
going to stay
they'll just get up i'm getting i have a
vid i'm having a vision
it's okay tv show idea i get percentage
beat bobby flay but in comedy beat neil
like beat like okay you think you're so
good at stand up
we'll see and then like have not the
problem with
bobby flay is you can you can hide the
dishes and
who made what you can't hide who told
what joke
if it's a famous person wait wait no i'm
saying the amateurs come
who think like this guy and the other
guy who wrote you're like i'm
fine i can [ __ ] do that job it's not
that hard and so they come up
and they work on obviously in hours way
too long but like a
10 this guy's saying he could do an hour
he doesn't know but that's what i'm
saying but
that's the bet is he could do an hour 15
minutes he just needs
three nights he needs three nights a
week for 10 weeks
and he'll do an hour as good as um
median level comedy store which is very
high level yeah
but i'm just saying this could be
interesting there i know of a show
that's right no one takes my idea but
but 15 minutes
no one's gonna beat someone in 15
minutes like it just
everyone will lose what do you mean
there's 50 minutes set to the store
yeah you're not gonna an amateur isn't
going to be able to beat
a professional in 15 minutes okay but
that's their fault that they think they
i know but it's not a good tv show why
because it's not interesting
i don't want to watch a bad thing for
more than 20 seconds
that's what this guy doesn't understand
he thinks it's gonna people are gonna be
patient
people will yell at you and then they'll
get up and leave
yeah you'd have to make it like if you
passed the three nights of practice and
people actually laughed
then but i mean no one's gonna
in order to do an hour this guy's saying
hey neil i see that if you can do an
hour and get it on netflix
you probably make minimum 400 grand a
year
and millions of people aren't doing that
because they just ha it hasn't occurred
to them
they just haven't all you got to do is
bear through it's not about material
right
anyone can write endless material
and any fool can do that a fool like
even though the only fools that have
been able to do it in world history
are like seven people but this guy
thinks
it's just a matter of like no and he
runs a gambling website
this isn't dunning krueger
this is not the dunning-kruger effect
this is he runs against
the batter he has he has an edge
and this is what i'm talking about it's
crazy that people think this
they but they don't think about
basketball they don't think about
singing they don't think about
they kind of do think about
screenwriting like well i'll just write
a thing and it'll give me everyone's
right because ben affleck did it 25
years ago and then never wrote
actually he wrote another thing matt
damon's written nothing else
um yeah i just mean sometimes like
before
i worked at a at a at comedy
places comedy clubs i liked the amateur
night
you know i liked kind of to see the bad
one like kill tony there is something
interesting like maybe not 15 minutes i
mean i'm not saying that like
this sociologically it's fascinating
right so i mean like
there is something kind of everyone gets
like i see the crowds that kill tony and
everyone
kinda wants you to bomb but they're
happy when you don't
but there is something about people
being like this guy thinks he can do
this guy thinks he can do comedy for an
hour
oh yeah i'm not talking you don't
understand how long an hour kill tony's
60 seconds no i know that i also i'm
mostly joking about this i feel like i'm
getting this guy's
no sense of humor this is not real yeah
this is not like the
bird movie i'm just saying that i do
there is something as an audience member
with like a lot less skin in this
argument i'm like i haven't i don't care
there is something interesting about
watching someone that
is cocky thinks he can do well
and bomb i know so well what's gonna
happen
that it's not even worth of course it's
like guy going i can beat
billie jean king it's i get at least
that guy was kind of a pro
okay this guy runs a gambling website
with an edge with an edge he's got an
edge um
and thinks that he can be a a
streaming netflix comedian it's
in 10 weeks
taking take comedy out of it
getting something that very few people
get which is a netflix
special or even a comedy special for
that matter and so few people even get
that and so many people are involved
in the steps to get there i mean like if
you just thought about this
if this guy just thought about it things
that are really hard to obtain
yeah there are hard to obtain for reason
so i think this guy's just you know but
that's what i don't
that's what i understand about that
people don't do the
they can't do that math especially
running a gambling website
yeah run the numbers why doesn't
everyone do
i promise you i made more than he did
most years
yeah like why would i think it's because
people
again people are you can be funny i
wanted it's the thing i wanted to play
last week
what about uh screwtape oh screwtape
um so good uh c.s lewis
wrote a uh a
book called the screw tape letters um
and uh and he basically
talks about how democracy
was um
[Music]
uh is the key to
it's the thing that makes everyone think
you're not better than me
because like we're all the same it's
like no our vote counts the same
after that we're all very different you
can't play it can you i can't play it i
can
uh so screwtape is like a demon and he's
giving a speech to
like demon university of demons um like
where they all go to school
in i guess in hell or something if
you look up if you look at the death of
expertise in the book
and um the
and the audiobook it's basically this
guy's screwtape
is a demon and he and he says um
just by merit of living in a democracy
it makes everybody think that
everything's
equal and the and it makes
it gives insecure people ammunition
like you're not better than me it's like
i'm better than you at
this one thing like this guy i couldn't
run a gambling website i have no problem
saying i couldn't be a options trader
maybe i could i don't know but i don't
assume
i could and it's not just temperamental
it's like i'm not
my gift isn't numbers yeah just don't
have a gift for numbers but because it's
not a
high status position i'm not gonna go
[ __ ] you
i anyone could do that all you gotta do
is get one of those chairs
with the it's i'm i just because it's
not high status
people have no i know it breeds no
resentment
where i think with a lot of people
with i think something about me
especially preach resentment no i don't
think it's you i think it is comedy
i think yeah i think also the yeah
podcast and the access people get
because people don't challenge you
on uh most people i mean i'm sure you
have a story but
i most people don't challenge you in
terms of chappelle show
now i could write that no one's saying
that oh no they don't have to because i
didn't write any of it
well i mean that's that's the other they
can't believe it
that's when i say that but that's a lot
of uh
most people i know you're gonna think
i'm crazy most people do
think you wrote no they do now they do
but they didn't until the mark 20 speech
i i know
people think i'm crazy when i say that
but most people because it's an
invisible job
you can't no one goes well mirror dave
seth
that corresponds dinner ellen and chris
you must [ __ ] be good at writing just
uh just why would those that's what i
was saying earlier it's like
because he's so nice i'm not nice he's
brave
yeah like i'm not nice so so it's
it's the thing about comedy that people
everyone's a little funny
and when someone goes on stage they're
basically saying i'm the funniest
and that makes especially men
cross their arms because it's it's
basically like i'm stronger than you
yeah and it's like a type of strength
women won't ever say i'm funny
but no woman and a woman will yell
in the middle of a show more than a man
because women
were wasted on pinot gris you're wasted
on pinot grige
and you don't have to fight you know
you're not gonna have to fight whereas
this guy probably wouldn't say this in
public
no um and even the idea of this is so
insane
he also wouldn't email joe rogan this
because he knows joe could beat him up
do you know what i mean there's just
these weird psychologies that people
don't take into account of like what are
you doing
you read so you really think so
comedians now
make between if you're doing if you're
streaming you're probably making between
500 grand and 100 million dollars right
let's say 500 grand on the low end
100 million kevin hart another guy i
work with
because i'm nice um and uh and
um and this guy thinks that it's just
a decision okay
that he could do also he just hasn't
because he doesn't want to
you know all this like it's you know he
doesn't want to sculpt material in front
of strangers and humiliate himself at
open mics and
bombing new material that's again why i
like jerry's thing on
on yeah on tim ferriss because jerry
like
illuminates what the job is
but i would say that everybody
there and this guy these this kind of
guy from the week before
are a bit more misguided than who i'm
talking about but there are people who
come to the store
and they want to start doing comedy and
they're probably the funniest person in
the friend group or whatever
you do have to kind of do comedy to see
if you can do it you know
i agree this other person that's like
when do you pull the plug
you you kind of you never have to you
really don't because it's kind of
innocuous yeah there is
it is a lottery no one's gonna say you
can't go on this open mic
no you won the lottery or some other
mics you bring
your bringer shows whatever they can't
stop you
it's just a matter of like how crazy are
you how insane are you that you think
that this is
any future to look forward to because it
is
very palpably embarrassing
and it's grueling it's not as glamorous
you think i mean what when did um
marin start popping late yeah
46. pop
that's when he started and he was that
was it's not like he started
boarding yeah so i
it you know what's funny too there's so
many people
who it takes a while i can't i maybe you
can i can't tell exactly when your
popcorn pops your colonel pops but
there's a
you could be doing comedy a lot and like
going up
i've had shows like a few times this
year or whatever and still like
i wouldn't consider you a yeah comedian
oh if you aren't going on
ev just about every night you're not a
comedian
that's the weird thing because people
think oh i go my friend goes over the
store some people will do
a random lady show here and there and
like i go to the store
they they self-identify as comedians
they write jokes
yeah they get laughs but i'm like
unless you're going up every night or
that's your main source of income
what this guy's not accounting for is
even people
i mean i've had the argument with rock
and jerry about
how much how many good hours can you do
right
in your life really if we're really
talking about it
three ouch i know but
think about it unfortunately i mean i
there were guys that i all
i would almost argue that burr
has had more what i consider like
top to bottom strong hours he's uh he is
a lot
then i don't i wouldn't say anybody but
like there was a
there was a there was a point where i
was like jesus christ like
and this guy thinks the only difference
between him and bill burr is
bill burr tried he doesn't understand
that like you know how much [ __ ]
material you have to just
pan for like seinfeld said on his thing
that's so funny they were
talking about um
[Music]
it wasn't kelly slater the other surfer
but he said like surfing
it's just paddling i surf every once in
a while
and at stand-ups like that it's like i
just i'm i'm writing jokes that
probably aren't gonna work yeah and i
couldn't
you could you couldn't tell me which
ones are gonna work or not
ahead of time i i don't know and i've
been doing it since i was 18.
so how would you close yeah
because your high status and i want that
and i do it every once in a while
i have a question do you think
i took this one like one of the most
interesting classes i took in college
this guy wrote his own book so he was
already weird but that my teacher
wrote a book on different nothing
weirder than writing a book go ahead
he wrote a book detailing different
types of
um science uh
like just like physics uh astronomy
like all the different types and he um
charted when at what age did they do the
most
amazing work i think you told me about
that i think i did it was like all
like all over like it was all well no it
depends like physics it was this age
right
you know and they actually never reached
that same level of
you know that yeah that peak they all
peak at different times in their life
and i'm wondering do you think comedians
do you think they peak or do you think
that because it's comedy the
the public changes on them and they
leave them
i don't know i but truthfully i don't
know because i don't i think it has
more to do with like how long
you've been doing stand-up
but you point make marin i mean marin
popped because of the
because of the podcast yeah um joe
popped because of the podcast
you think joe bob he was pretty big yeah
but it was concurrent
it was he's the podcast is bigger than
the stand up
okay yeah as a comic he's been famous
for a long time yeah um
the i i don't know because i think i'm
funnier now
than i've ever been which might just be
motivated reasoning and and confirmation
bias
i want to be funnier right but i started
later so
and then there's so i'd but maybe i was
technically
my brain was a more active
i ne i just my my i have a better eye
for what
probably will work that's from oh that's
from doing it
but i think there it's like you have the
eye for what probably will work and then
then culture is a whole other thing in
terms of what people want to hear and
then
and then i really like dave like dave
kind of
disappearing for a decade
was helpful to his career because
meanwhile he gets
people never got tired of him yeah so
like he's just like a new thing that
they're like oh [ __ ]
right new generation of people get to
like appreciate him in a different way
also
yeah because i there's there's and then
you get like
less angry what do you mean you just get
less angry as a person you get to have
kids
you just get softer your edges get
softer
because there's comics who come to this
store who at some point were the biggest
comic in the entire world
and i'm like it's funny yeah like i get
the i get the humor but i'm not
dying laughing so i'm wondering did they
are they still
playing the same song and it just feels
like yeah it's
impossible to say because it's also like
you're
i've gotten better in that i just
am i'm like okay i just can't i just i
really don't care
i used to not care about what people
thought of me and now it's the point
where it's
i i'm gonna say whatever what like i
there's a thing about your personal
orientation to the world that i think is
a big
which i think to burst credit is another
thing that he hasn't
burr's [ __ ] rich and you'd never know
it
uh oh a normal person yeah yeah i'm like
i kind of feel like he's
he's always smoking cigars i don't know
it's a rich guy thing but you can get
cigarettes at 7-eleven
okay like a white house yeah like maybe
he's but he doesn't
he drives a prius last time i checked
like oh yeah no he's chill he's not
a fl he's but he i
also i'm from silicon valley so i see a
lot of rich people and they that's how
rich
that's how silicon valley goes yeah
they're sebastian rich and has
no no sebastian is easter is rich
like no silicon he's like silicon valley
he's just like
i'm not changing anything i'm wearing
regular things yeah
i'm not like changing up
well i'm really rich if yes and he still
has a
bad he still has an anger issue which is
great
it's hard to do it really is hard to do
to
have money and a good marriage and
children that you love
and still be a [ __ ] angry maniac
is like a gift well especially good for
his comedy that's what i'm
yes i i don't know he's not raging i
mean
yeah but on in like the fact that he can
keep up the same
it's almost like some people what made
their first album was amazing because
they were more like raw
yeah talent like burr's talent is still
in all of his
yeah it's still like the same [ __ ]
yeah
that's what makes him so [ __ ] funny
um
but this guy could do it he just needs
10 he needs 30
30 sets um and we'll just give him what
we get
which is by the way he's not taking the
wager
by the way none of us get i'm not going
to take the waiter because i literally
won't do that to the audience no one
will sit
for a guy i'm not gonna give a main room
audience i'm not gonna give somebody an
hour in the main room
to prove something that he doesn't know
that i know
in my essence and any comedian in the
world
so all these people say how hard is g
you can listen to jerry on the other
thing
he'll tell you how hard it is and then
you can be like nah me
no what's the what's the line on that
football game um
um so sorry sorry boss um that's the
podcast for this week
and we did it and we don't have to take
this [ __ ]
it's december and
no more [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you